sweet awesome all right
all right going live
all right friends you know what time it
is you know the drill
let us know are we live can you see us
can you hear us can you feel us
we did not tease this at all that we
were going live no but it's okay who's
in the chat just tell us who's in the
chat right now sound 29 people at the
very top here Tamar how you doing Blanco
Dog Productions what's going on Kevin
Shepard fast X that's right I did hear
the fast X news did you hear the fast X
news oh there's fast X news John you
were always not up to date what is the
deal here what happened did Dwayne
Johnson come back oh come on John you
got to understand
you got to understand I I understand if
I just keep saying that will you
eventually I understand I do understand
that's so crazy what happened with fast
10 no fast X Gal Gadot oh she out is she
back she out she's back she uh she have
a complaint about it she's back from
fast six right she was in fast six yeah
furious six furious six Jesus John come
on Fast Five you gotta know these things
I do thank you let's go back to the chat
while I don't know what you're doing
right now but you're doing stuff oh
that's cool yeah oh would you put it in
the center of the box
neat stuff right here
um you guys shouts out to your Iron
Giant sweater Maddie hello thank you so
much cesca and uh thank you to all the
congratulations I really appreciate that
j4 thank you very much got married over
the weekend
in case you guys don't know so thank you
yeah
it's it's all downhill from here that's
right we're filing for divorce that's
right you did it you got that one
Milestone now you gotta go right to the
next month we did it let's go yeah yeah
we didn't tease that we're going live at
all but I should probably mention that
we're live on some social medias right
now yeah do it thoughts on The Witcher
season four well it's gonna be the best
season I'll tell you guys Henry Cavill
is a toxic gamer I want to watch the
first episode and make it's you know
there's all this talk about The Witcher
season four because capital's leaving
that I um
completely forgot that we did not get a
season three That season three hasn't
aired yet yes I know and I'm like oh
yeah we got we got one more with Henry
Cavill I totally forgot that we we still
have that to come out yeah that has
totally overshadowed that fact in my
mind this whole Chris Liam Hemsworth
three casting news so that's good I mean
we at least got eight to ten more cavals
right yeah that's true that's very true
that's very true
um so who do we got here Marseille
Productions thank you so much Orlando I
haven't seen Wednesday yet no I'm not
not seeing that I might watch it on my
own time to be honest I'll watch it for
you guys yeah yeah you do it John
Brendan Dean is saying Indiana Jones
five Obi Dawn don't you need to have a
kid first to save the marriage before
divorce oh damn dude gotta get on there
no no no no no borrow someone's kid now
if we have a kid when we have a kid I'll
just uh cut the kid in half and she'll
get the bottom half I'll get the better
half it's a good thing you guys clearly
learned the right take away from the
King Solomon story or whatever that is
yeah it's true that's true yeah split
that baby Quentin Marcus I'm assuming
he's talking about The Witcher season
four what if they do the Amnesia Arc and
use the actor change in Witcher to make
us feel geralt's confusion
I mean that could be cool but I feel
like the payoff would ultimately what I
want goes back to being Henry Capital at
some point not just staying confused
forever and turning out to be some other
duck guy all together hey if you guys
are here can you um can you just leave a
like even if you're planning on only
being here for like five seconds just if
you can leave a like you know I I feel
like sometimes when I ask that it sounds
like on your end that's going to be a
lot of a lot of effort but it's not it
is so just leave a like that'd be
appreciated very appreciated John let's
read the super chat right here Omni uh
omni432. thank you for the Super Chat my
friend omnisy for squeezing that's right
we're live normally we go live a little
bit earlier I know yeah guys so what uh
we have not seen Puss in Boots yet I'm
actually I actually think we should
react to that here I would love to react
to that um to catch up on the whole puts
and put some boots averse I want to
um re-read the I mean it's just right
here we could just just go right okay
there we go look we cut away to it for a
brief moment hey looky there I don't
think this is gonna work
I'm not a fan of the visual
that's the old one let's just scroll up
and read it all right all right let's
scroll up Scroll up here we're trying to
trying some new visuals out right I
think I'm just gonna bring someone in
one day I ask too much of John for these
situations omni432 thank you so much for
the Super Chat my friend and if you guys
do contribute I really do appreciate it
thank you um it means a lot and also we
have streamlabs open as well how excited
are you for Scream Six I'm very excited
for scream six I think Scream Six is
um John you talk first I want I want you
all right you go first please buddy I
mean I'm excited for Scream Six partly
because you know I mean it's a chance
like I think we both share this opinion
of scream five of like yeah there's
there's a lot of stuff I like about it
but I don't love it quite the way
everybody else does and what excites me
is that uh radio silence and that team
will be able to take they've seemed very
enthusiastic about making this one their
own and really going all out and going
No Holds Barred and I feel like you know
because Wes Craven shepherded the
franchise up until part four I think
that's the appropriate thing to do I
feel like maybe the aspects of scream
five I didn't love were aspects that
were kind of held down by having to be
like respectful of the original not
maybe being able to go as all out as as
you want to and for a franchise that
will eventually you know shed all of its
original parts if we're gonna keep it
going I think some new and fresh energy
is merited so I hope they deliver on
that and I like I like the cheekiness of
taking it to New York you know there's
going to be a lot of Jason Takes man
Manhattan you know ribbing across the
movie I am sure as well as any other new
york-based horror movies but that's you
know one of the most you know Meme
worthy of them all so I I hope good
things what do you think sir
I think that you and koi have the
hardest time whenever this camera
whenever the uh monitor is in front of
us you guys just look at each other
that's right man you look at yourselves
the whole time I love to I'm just gonna
stare at it because we have them on we
can see ourselves on the screen here and
especially koi when koi is here he just
does not break eye contact with himself
it is the most fascinating thing to to
watch this dude
I looked at the people you were looking
at your phone I'm trying to figure out
because I'm I'm trying to share this on
Instagram yeah and and I'm trying to say
I'm saying doing it live for the link
yes but I'm like but what if they read
it like doing it live so I'm like What's
the best way to communicate that it's a
live stream in a way that doesn't just
say live streams so oh yeah yeah I think
that's that's like multiple eyes here to
try to make it work yes I think that's
good though I think that does work I
think that was a good strategy this is
gonna be a real hangout live stream in
case you guys didn't notice and he's
always all of our live streams are very
official I said that in real Hangouts
too
this is not going to be a corporate
hangout it's not going to very
structured or scheduled out hangout it's
just gonna be a hangout let's keep going
through here it's like you're actually
hanging out with me while we're hanging
out here I'll control I'll let can you
mind if I control the please oh my God
look at that you can see this in real
time you can even see the comments that
um are flagged that's the weird part
about this yeah isn't that fun you guys
can't but now you can yeah through our
vision so there's no point there's no
point of having any of those comments
flagged that's the funny part about it
yeah
um let's see here across the spider
verse yes um I definitely looking
forward to that I helped that with the
thumbnail
on the well they've after they filmed it
and um yeah I do want to see across the
spider verse that looks awesome does
looks amazing it does I feel like that
that movie is gonna be uh much bigger
than people realize yeah oh dude I mean
the first one was since the first movie
is like accepted as the best animated
movie of all time
by a lot of people like yeah Chris
Donahue thank you Chris for the Super
Chat Guardians the Galaxy vol 3 is going
to be the movie of the year I love you
also congrats on the wedding Greg thank
you Chris Donahue I think Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 is gonna be one
emotional ass film emotional ass it's an
interesting yeah an ass of emotions what
the critics are gonna say big old donk
Hollywood Reporter says Ass of emotions
of emotions James got delivered on the
ass of emotion cheeks of emotional
resonance that's right yeah yeah
um yeah I think I I was I was kind of
wondering you know because James guns so
much in the controversial eye right now
with the DC stuff I'm imagine we'll end
up talking about that at some point
during the stream uh he's so much in the
eye of the DC stuff that I wonder if
um any of that lens might reflect onto
people's association with volume like if
it's great will the people get more
excited for DC or what I mean if it's
bad people might get it you know what I
mean I'm like well
when he headed over to DC I guess what
I'm getting at is is
the reception of volume three going to
have an impact on the anticipation for
the DC Universe that's where I'm getting
at which I think would be fascinating
experience yeah well we'll eat it up and
we'll make videos yeah we will Stoke
that controversy fire
quantumania Dune two I keep forgetting
Dune two is coming yeah same but I am
excited for Dune are you are you excited
for Daredevil Born Again of course not
never ever I'm gonna hate all 40
episodes It's not gory enough God damn
it according to Mr Cox Matt Charlie Cox
is having too much sex on set are you
guys hanging out on Christmas no for the
love of God please stay with you other
people
or one break from each other there is a
new Evil Dead movie which uh there's
only been like photos for it hasn't
there yeah but I'm excited nonetheless I
mean they're also doing that like we're
going to the everyone's going to the
city in 2023 oh is that what they're
doing yeah it's in like an apartment
building or something like that oh weird
yeah and it's about this like it's like
a a single mom or something with her
daughter and uh yeah all hell breaks
loose in this apartment complex I guess
that sounds fun yeah I mean the director
is is well renowned in this sort of
indie horror circuit so I'm excited to
see I think it's Lee Cronin whose films
I have not seen but uh you know you're
always I'm always curious when somebody
comes out of you know that corner true
true and I feel like evil dead and Sam
raimi's uh you know just sort of
organization is good at finding folks
who are up and coming in the horror
circuit and I got a question if we split
apart a little bit more sure this will
look even better could we make this
bigger sure oh yeah John do your thing
yeah that way on the playback you can
see it you see those messages right
there where it says show hide we get
those all the time and normally we just
keep them hidden because they usually
say words like that
there you go that's nice and pretty
right there you go now now because most
people think watch from their phones
yeah so we got a nice little split
screen and now we now we're sitting much
farther apart
or a couple going through a really hard
time right now we can't handle the
intimacy
can't do this McCoys here we're just
recording the center and just put this
and put the chat over here that just
lets you listen that's okay I mean
that'll probably bring Coy's energy
right to an equal equal level without
the visual component raccoon shampoo
thank you so much for the super chat
buddy John why don't you read that yes I
wonder what's happening with that Keanu
Reeves Constantine sequel that was
confirmed rumored I can't remember under
the new regime you think it'll be folded
in oh highly doubt it I highly doubt it
I mean it's a sequel to a movie before
the DC EU even existed yeah so I I
highly doubt about it but I I think to
me I think with the DC Universe it's I
kind of I kind of liken it to our
opinion of Chucky sure of what I of what
I think James Gunn is attempting to do
where you're not gonna necessarily
disregard everything that came before it
but you will evolve it and yeah and have
it reshape itself like no don't try to
go those sucked ignore it you know and
and I think that with that's why I I
think he was public he didn't have put
out a public yeah I did a video about it
he did he did say uh he responds to
someone that they are uh yeah they are
actively developing an elseworld side of
it so I think Constantine would just if
they do proceed forward with it would
just continue on into the elseworld side
of things but I'm excited for it man
it's a real 50 50 in terms of likelihood
now but I I hope it happens and I cannot
wait to sync up with your reaction when
I finally watch the first
it I'm gonna do it I want to sync up
with you uh let's see more DC animated
movie reactions please is panning out
well yeah I'm so happy about that those
are absolute blasts yeah man those are
good those are fun they are dude hey I'm
jealous I mean you've seen so many of
them and I have so many to look forward
to that's why I gave the idea to you
guys thank you I gotta credit myself
here you should I gotta just so AK
myself on the back for uh saying like
hey you guys haven't seen these you
should do them so much of what you see
here is Greg's ideas even if Greg is
nowhere near the screen to present those
ideas so yeah no absolutely call
producing dude your producer I'm a
Tarantino like producer I come in and I
go I came up with this bam look at me
look at me Greg albra presents John and
Coy's reaction to under the Red Hood
that's good I was doing analytical
research and here's what I discovered
yeah man and knowing what you guys have
told me about your viewing experience
Dakota Jones Thank You Dakota one virus
huh folks coder's the man smash that
like button listen to Sean C right here
smash that like if you're here thank you
Dakota from Super Chat I love Sean did I
read the last one under you yeah I read
the last one you should read is this one
Greg ah congrats my man to see you
always happy always never all never a
sad moment in my life especially on
those particular YouTube videos Merry
Christmas list cracking of the whole
time oh yeah Merry Christmas to both as
a horror fan Scream Six I knew I should
have put ghost's face in the thumbnail
dude I was so back and forth I was so
bad I failed your own taste
um I kept going back for Barbie Indiana
Jones which one
but the first one that came to mind was
Ghostface and I think ghost fish really
works well in a thumbnail I mean sure
keeps getting brought up
um but yeah as a horror fan scream
sticks Oppenheimer is my number one
Oppenheimer does look great uh did you
see the trailer did you ever watch it I
have not seen the trailer yet I hear if
you if you go to IMAX or Avatar in
general I think it might be an IMAX
trailer yeah like a special kind of
trailer for it because you know Nolan
likes to do that first films we always
put some special look yeah it's an IMAX
and I I did I love the trailer a lot and
it looks like pure Nolan and I like that
he's kind of going back to those days of
memento and insomnia combined because
people forget about that age of Nolan
sure before it was just like
expositional living I was just literally
just listening to a discussion about it
was like a real or something it was
Double Toasted Chris Herman was talking
about how Nolan now feels like like
highbrow Michael Bay and like since
Inception it is mostly just like plot
and Technical [ __ ] yeah whereas before
that it was like interesting ideas and
characters stuff and and yeah and even
just from the outside with the images
I've seen and knowing what the subject
matter is I'm very very part of me is
like I'm gonna watch the trailer but
it's one of those movies where like I
don't even have to because I know I'm
excited to see it because a I love who's
in it but B I think this is a good
convergence for the modern Christopher
Nolan to come back to something that
would be a bit more human but also you
know he can entertain all of his many
technical predilection in the process
they created some kind of crazy way to
capture nuclear explosions on camera so
you know
they blew up parts of the they went to
Republicans based cities they just
started nuking all the reddest counties
the wokest movie ever yeah that they
bombed
all the right cities they wiped a lot of
places off the map
uh yeah I I roll Hollywood I was um on
the because we we got married in
Colorado and on the car ride back to
keep myself awake I watched a couple of
movies I just put it on my phone and
while you were driving yeah I mean and
there are times you got to pause because
it gets because it was an 18-hour drive
so sometimes at night you can't see [ __ ]
those movies going away because I can't
see anything yeah yeah of course
um but I listened to a documentary about
Oppenheimer and he is a fascinating
individual and uh I didn't know he was
diagnosed with schizophrenia and he like
refused to to buy into it and I wonder
if Nolan will lean into that his wife
got a round of marriage
this is the fourth marriage I mean
you're married to something else
entirely when you're in a guy like
that's position yeah all right Angie
Kelly thank you for the super chat
um killers of the flower moon are you
excited for that's a decaprio one that
is Scorsese one which justices which got
really some recasting right didn't they
get some recasting going
killers of the flower Moon IMDb
yeah directed by Melvin Scorsese oh yeah
that's right this is the one that that
puts DiCaprio and De Niro uh back
together again under the directions yeah
of course I'm excited for this yeah
Clemens John Lithgow Brendan Fraser
what is a Brendan Fraser the Fraser
science is here oh he's that massively
fat guy he's the super fat guy from all
those fat sad guys
[Laughter]
right from the manipulative or very
beautiful human movie depending on who
you talk to I'm so when do when he came
back with Doom Patrol people have been
where's Brandon Fraser been I'm like
dude Patrol he's gonna do Patrol
he's been around he's been here for a
while now but I I I am excited I love
Darren aerosity films I I am a fan of
that misery that he loves to portray on
screen I I eat it up so can we expect a
whale reaction I don't want to do a
reaction to well but I'm I'm trying to
catch in the theater before the end of
the year yeah I'm Max 3D um but yeah
killers of the flower Moon of course I
don't need to see a trailer I'm
obligated to be excited absolutely
that's a Netflix movie right yeah Jesse
Yeah man Scorsese for as much as he
loves Cinema he's over in Netflix's
pocket right now thank you all for being
here guys thank you all for being here
please leave a like if you are here yeah
yeah yeah like it let's see here let's
see here
um what was the mouse where's the mouse
you guys can't see this but we can't
find them there all right Kyle you got
the mouse tells me how many people
created false rumors for Indy five I
know casual fans already talking bad
about the movie because of Doom [ __ ] and
uh that Doom [ __ ] he's he's got a he's
got a power hold man
I first discovered him through the Star
Wars I guess this thing is like bashing
on Lucas Films would probably not he's a
real Rebel Rouser that guy Wiseman uh at
least anticipated movie of all time has
to be the next Avatar movie the second
one was avatarded
disagree but that's your I quite enjoyed
it I am enjoying God of War someone
follows the Greg on Insta I am enjoying
it um TL I'm sorry but who is genuinely
ex watching Barbie for the script it's
just a bunch of sad boys wanting to
watch the actress Oppenheimer solos dude
I mean I'm super excited for Barbie and
I'm super excited for it to subscribe
invert that very opinion did you ever
hear the story of uh that Ryan Gosling
told about why he took on Ken no because
uh Greta girl were called him up he
loved the script but then when he was
like wondering if he should do it he
went out to his backyard and one of his
kids left the Ken doll buried in the
ground like face down in the dirt and he
like took a photo of it he's like I'll
be your kid incidentally he did that
because they knew did the kid know no no
it was like I need to stand to forget
yeah
so that's awesome I'm excited I hope
Barbie delivers on being more than it
more than you would expect it to be from
the outset and because Barbie is the
icon that she is culturally speaking I
have a feeling that they wouldn't have
allowed this movie to happen if it was
just going to be like a shitty cash crab
it's fair enough you know fair enough
Michael Bay's Barbie is is not going
forward I've seen a lot of love for Doom
2 Loki season two obviously Ahsoka I am
very very excited for Soca I gotta get
one of my Star Wars peeps on with me or
that one that's I mean it's so Katana
you're getting the rebel story
continuing come on Boom come on people
boom leaving out a lot of people who did
not take the time to watch Rebels going
what the hell is going on in this show
okay
require us to do sure they'll still have
complaints even though they didn't see
it Invincible season two oh it's
Invincible season two coming back this
year oh nice out call up Aaron Alexander
I'll see here let's see here this is
this is just so people know that we
actually ask of emotions Greg 2022 don't
hide that YouTube ass motions Blue
Beetle is my most anticipated DC movie
of next year and sometimes when you talk
about representation people get upset
and how dare you I am excited for the
representation though of that movie I am
too that's I would love to contribute to
that to part of the conversation because
I don't think this is mar does Marvel
have like a a a a Latino lead
in one of their MCU like like the actual
like the Title Character not until we
get that Louise movie
that David Cronenberg is working yes so
that's that I'm here for that already
experience he tries to become an actual
he tries to cover and then he'll be like
man spider yeah yeah it'll be good uh
let's let's just Google Latino leads in
the MCU it's it's got to be tennis
Huerta who's even still a supporting
character there's just seven Latinos who
have appeared oh yeah there's some
actors
yeah but but nobody's LED one yet I mean
Oscar Isaac is he's Latino right but
yeah he's but Mark spector's is he like
Jewish Latino or just
Jewish like polish Jefferson
isn't uh Oscar Isaac like he's he's like
Ecuadorian or something like that yeah I
don't think it figures into playing Mark
Spector I only know Mexican John yeah
yeah that's that's it I can't I don't
think I don't know everything below
America yeah it's just one big Mexico
I don't know of any other one a wheel of
time seeing Mexico that's Little Mexico
that's Mexico right under America that's
Maine Mexico if you're not if you
haven't done it yet leave a like uh
Quentin Marcus thank you again for
another Super Chat did you guys react to
the animated Witcher prequel no we
watched it though we needed to cram it
in so we could watch season two which
apparently a lot of fans did not like
but I I did like that prequel that was a
cool badass prequel for sure yeah sweet
it was a good animated you know it was
nice and gritty had some nice horror
elements to it like didn't he write
Guardians of the Galaxy script like five
years ago though I'm sure it's evolved
over time and he didn't touch it once
Omni 432 congratulations on the wedding
thank you very much well done dude
what's the best part about being married
now the best part about being married is
the level of
um assuredness that you have of a
partner constantly there for you oh
that's very sweet
um it's a real answer it's awesome I
think that is a good one you I agree
Brendan K I'm most excited for cocaine
bear to enter the MCU Brendan K thank
you for the Super Chat cocaine bear is
gonna be did you see the trailer for
that I don't know no but you know what
I've I I saw a piece of the trailer
because I discovered that that guy who
does those funny reels on Instagram with
the mustache and uh he's got kind of a
tall head he's in it as like a paramedic
so I was like oh hey that Instagram
comedian I think is funny
hey cocaine bear I remember when that
story hit the news cycle and so that's
another movie where I'm like trailer or
no I'm just excited and I wish we could
do a reaction but uh it seems like the
title alone would probably destroy that
entire endeavor
yeah man I mean I I know some people who
got age restrictions on Glass Onion
today what why I know I don't know glass
is dangerous and onions might make you
cry so no idea uh and
I I like there's certain words that I
want to say right now that I'm like
maybe because this word was in there
because I intentionally muted some words
uh there's this particular word I muted
in that in that movie that I was like I
have it's basically the word we had to
mute all through smile yes of course
because I I know that if you just say
that which is weird because there's a DC
movie two of them
and never an age restriction but they
must have whitelisted that phrase or
something maybe but for some reason uh
yeah when you talk about the subject uh
it it it and if you use the actual word
they if you've seen the movie smile you
you know you have to conclude what word
we are referencing to right now dude did
you know I discovered do you know who
the lead of smile is
no soci bacon no is is the daughter of
Kyra Sedgwick and Kevin Kevin Bacon oh I
should have put that together no it's
just like you hear the name and you're
like it must be so obvious but but yeah
I know it's nothing like Kevin Bacon
yeah exactly so uh yeah that's that's
the case oh cool yeah killing the game
no wonder she's terrible yeah she's
terrible and got to work she's horrible
terrible yeah you come from a rich
successful parent actors you are
naturally terrible Hey listen Lily Rose
has a lot to say about that money
they'll leave you it's pain um I'm
excited for the new Hunger Games home
I'm not I'm sorry I'm not I have no
interest in that filming you don't want
to see Corey Elena's Snow's origin story
I have zero interest in that film what
do you guys most keep talking why didn't
you put spider verse in the thumb oh the
thing is I I kept going back and forth
because because I was like I need at
least one animated movie I think I'm
gonna go with Mario because we already
got a king in here to represent Marvel
sure sure
present a bunch of Corners yeah yeah and
and um and originally was just gonna be
movies but then today I was like oh
people are going to probably bring up TV
shows some might as well uh yeah and uh
so that's why I was back and forth was
like Indiana Jones represent the
lucasfilm side but I'm like I got some
new franchises let me put Barbie in here
yeah
um Mission Impossible dead reckoning yes
oh yes God I can't wait for that Tommy
Cruz when we got back from Colorado I
was going to react to the stunt video
and then I was like you know what I'm
just gonna wait oh because I remember
when I watched Fallout the they did the
whole stunt video surrounding the the
Halo drop the Halo drop and I remember
really liking that video
but I I think I had a split moment just
that split moment it stuck with me I
wish I never saw that behind the scenes
video I wish I watched that after the
movie yeah yeah for them yeah yeah and I
get it builds hype and and I'm usually
the guide for that uh but I this time
around like let me just let me just
because I did that with top gun Maverick
and I love the experience of going how
did they shoot this [ __ ] because I have
no idea like this is wild yeah yeah
totally and then to go back and find out
later I'm like oh that's cool yeah yeah
there's a reason you save special
features for the DVD but you never know
you never know you never do if you have
to choose new spider-verse or Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 oh oh Guardians three
because it has to conclude because like
spider-verse is so good on its own and
I'm excited to see it continue but yeah
Guardians 2 I didn't love I don't think
you loved either and three just has so
many different Stakes for the characters
for James Gunn for all of it like yeah
um David Fincher's next movie The Killer
next year David Adventure wow Dave
Fisher just went right back to basic
City
it's gonna be a straight up murderer
Thriller killer serial killer this is
what I like to do leave it at that
it's going to be good though who's in it
do we know have you heard anything about
it no I'm it's a David Fincher movie
called killer probably not a a slow
self-indulgent film like the Citizen
Kane movie what was that oh yeah uh the
mank couldn't do it couldn't do it I'm
not I'm not artistic enough you're not
you're not up for the bank I'm not
artistic and I could watch Misery porn
from Darren arnofsky but I cannot do I
could not do mink oh dude it's gonna do
it assassin begins to psychologically
crack as he develops a conscience even
as his clients continue to demand his
skills gotta change his title not a fan
of the title okay Tilda Swinton Michael
Fassbender I hate the title The Killer
honestly it is a very painter title it
is a very straightforward if that's the
graphic novel title I hate it and you
know there was a guy two hours of 30
years
definitive killer after this no more
on-screen Killers this is the last one
Jesus Christ that's a very long film
last one Finch
um let's see here thank you to all who
are here this is such an impromptu one
so thank you all for being here
uh I don't think we're gonna react to
bad batch honestly
um there's some other things I'm working
on out outside of this and I would like
to use the time of it and honestly the
interest is just not there with the
channel when it comes to it it takes so
much time
it does not it's not even break even for
whatever other time and extra financial
investments it takes it's very fun and
enjoyable but it's easily the least
viewed thing yeah I will still watch it
because I'm I'm a Star Wars fan and I
consume that [ __ ] so I also watch it but
I I'm just going to use that time for
myself and then prepare my body for the
Crazy Nights of the last of us but
that's that's what I'm going to do
um let's see here hey love from
Bangladesh thank you so much how's it
going uh thank you so much it's okay if
you can't send super chess don't worry
but we appreciate everyone who does and
you guys are a little bit more special
hey here's the deal if you can't send a
Super Chat just leave a like maybe even
put a comment on the actual video itself
uh I ooh Maverick over the way of water
fascinating question because I I think
those two films represent two beautiful
opposing spectrums exactly of of Cinema
exactly and in all its Glory I really
mean that because one is the
demonstrative you know Showcase of
practical and stunts and and all these
all that craziness yeah it's it's so
gorgeous
um whereas and then avatars the complete
opposite which is the technical Marvel
of special effects CGI how much ground
can we break at one point but they both
warrant
um cinematic experience I I feel like
Maverick at the end of the day for me
personally sure yeah I would agree with
that like I'll there's there's a lot
about way of water I will happily defend
and and and you know express my
appreciation for but man Maverick I
think partly just due to the fact that
Maverick is more easy to digest package
of a movie it's true it's not three
hours and change you know like I feel
like you gotta really like gear yourself
up a little bit for Avatar you got to
really be wanting to jump into that war
whereas with Maverick you can go for the
intensity and you can go for the fun and
they kind of coalesce together yeah
because I'm trying to even I'm not the
guy who's like into Aviation or that
[ __ ] uh but the but that movie
like just makes you want to be more into
like I have no interest in seeing like
the one that has the guy from Top Gun
Maverick oh Glenn about the major Glenn
Powell Jonathan fly boys or something
I have no interest not fly boys but yes
I know a terrible time of the year for
that film to come out yeah do not want
to follow that movie after top gun
Maverick has come out you just don't
want to do that yeah people are just
going to be sitting there being like why
am I why am I not watching topic right
now oh yeah it's it's good though it's
good devotion that's devotion that's the
name it's not fly boys no fly boys is an
earlier movie isn't James Franco or
somebody in Flyboys it's like a period
piece God I don't know I'm taking this
back John either way as much as you want
to research devotion that's right I
don't think that is the uh Welcome to
our devotion live stream breaking down
all the fine points of the new Glenn
Powell picture Imperial lame it's going
well
um I mean I'm sure the Hunger Games
prequel is gonna be awesome yeah that
one guy who directed them all is back
Peggy Francis Lawrence yeah really yeah
Peggy coming let it go man you and the
guy who do Harry Potter you need to let
it go he did do Constantine which I
really liked and um he should do
something else I liked Catching Fire a
lot sure I did too both Hunger Games and
Bourne Identity have that thing with
their franchise where the director who
took over the second one is known as the
one who helmed it and so the sort of the
recent Planet of the Apes sure yeah well
I'm like Matt Reeves and not direct the
first
um Paul Greengrass and not to direct the
first
and Francis Lawrence did not direct
first Gary Wright yeah yeah but their
names are the ones that said like for
some reason they're like even though the
first one was a massive hit you're the
one you were the weak link sir get out
of here get this director they stay from
now on forget it's changing up the Harry
Potter's David Yates this is your thing
from now on yeah strange film punch
thank you for the Super Chat dude
hey Greg and John that's us John why
don't you read this one Spencer from
film punch pop oh from Paul you've
renamed your shouting
you ever listen to the playbacks here
and they get loud yeah I know I'm sorry
here I'll I'll modulate hurt
s
uh yeah no no film punch Spencer you
renamed your podcast I I totally forgot
but yes uh from film punch slash pop
culture podcast here just wanted to send
a Super Chat and say my most anticipated
as Guardians 3 plus I would love to
interview you both for my Chanel did you
start up an actual Channel yeah are you
on are you on the tube now or are you
still on um that that podcast platform
that I have the app for whose name
eludes me now
uh
Pulitzer broadcast
Oh you mean the app yeah that thing that
we logged into to do the show yeah
well yeah let's talk about it man let's
do it but the Guardians 3 uh the
Guardians I was I was doing research
regarding three and Ant-Man trying to
see like which one are people most
anticipating and I think Guardians 3 is
actually the one oh yeah people are more
interested in I mean your research is
probably more comprehensive than my
anecdotal it was about 30 seconds but I
do get the distinct sense that Guardians
3 probably is the one because Ant-Man
still has to live up and not every movie
viewer watched Loki you must assume they
got Kong in there yeah
um raccoon that it's not a I wasn't I
was the joke was on mispronouncing it
yeah along the Kong yeah
I want people to read into that raccoon
shampoo thank you again raccoon raccoon
put koi in a green screen too but just
his head sticking out of the middle put
the chat over the green screen
it would be very funny nothing would
mess with Coy's self-esteem more than
him just being a voice and not having
his face oh my God he must be seen yeah
he must be he can be a floating head
that's enough I want to say I would make
this joke to his face to make it sound
like it's okay I'm making fun of his ego
but no I think it would hurt his ego
more
[Laughter]
you can't you can't say anything about
koi even a compliment without him
freaking out on you he's not in the
video he won't watch this yeah he does
he's not he's not gonna comment his mom
won't come into the chat and keep us on
the right track either mom's a
sweetheart better in person absolutely
sweetheart lucky
um what's up koi's Mom hey Jay Bowers
you got a really sweet comment here
um I just want to let you guys know you
both helped me through so much by
posting videos on YouTube I've had tough
times lately and you guys make those
days better so thank you so much dude I
that means a lot man thank you I we just
a lot of times we have to remind
ourselves like our goal with the video
is just sometimes you got to go look we
just wanna
entertain people make someone laugh or
smile or or yeah or harmonize with your
experience worst thing we watched this
year oh ooh do you have do you have one
there's got to be an answer to this
what's the worst thing we watch I don't
think I watched the new thing that was
terrible yeah
there's got to be something and like let
me go back through all the movies I've
seen some terrible things it must have
been like some episode of a TV show that
was like the worst thing I've seen
I'm not sure what it might have been but
[Music]
thank you doe eyes for the Super Chat
John we are reading a Super Chat to get
our undivided attention we are congrats
on the wedding Greg thank you John
are you guys for Barbie
I mean I saw some people's posts about
it saying that it looked really awful
um what what how much how much do you
have to judge off that I know right
I am I am excited in an ironic not in in
both a genuine and an ironic way because
you know I mean like obviously we grew
up in a time where things were not as
progressed as they are now so you know
Barbies for girls I don't like Barbie
but for me I keep coming back to this
idea of like yeah you know like they got
film people to make it and they also
must be aware like you know I've seen
like at least a documentary or two about
the legacy of bar like there's something
about Barbie that seems like it
Necessities that made us no it was not
the toys
I tried dinging you there I'm pretty
sure I saw that episode you didn't watch
something that was like oh Niche it was
the most popular thing yes or something
as well but like yeah I've seen at least
accounts of Barbie Through the Ages and
what this figure this doll means and I
was like okay like hearing about that it
seems like there's more significance
there than a lot of other other
prominent notable toys that would be
brought up on the toys that made us or
others for sure so knowing all of that
as as like kooky and strange and and I
roll as part of the idea is I am
actually really hoping that they can
nail it just because it seems like the
right toy movie to be you know brought
to life in a pretty surprisingly good
packaging I think out of all the trailer
reactions we've done I want to say it's
my favorite reaction but I think in
terms of a discussion after a trailer
that was my that was one of my favorites
I'm really looking forward to it yeah I
think I think they can make something
really unique and and
and surprising sure um cheeky yeah yeah
I think they can do something really
special there so I I'm looking forward
to it a lot
I don't know where I got the Star Wars
shirt I'm not gonna lie I I have no
recollection of where I got this I've
had for years and I I don't remember
where I got it I feel like it's like a
Hot Topic or something definitely not or
was it like it might have been like a
box one of those box things like a geek
uh it was it was probably like a Super
Geek box
damn that Jonas Brothers in devotion we
still got the devotion trailer
there's a Jonas in it it's Nick John or
you Joe or Craig or whichever Jones
you've got a lot of love for that this
is my favorite Christmas sweater it's my
Iron Giant and he's got little deer that
he doesn't want to shoot it's perfect
couldn't find the time to commit to
Wednesday uh at the time because I had
to prep that's why that sort of movie
reactions went up because I was trying
to prep as much in advance in order to
so I would not have to you know do any
uh editing or filming while I was away
which I ended up doing almost everything
yeah I was not complaining I'm just like
yeah I just entered up the optician I'm
just I don't know why I prep so much in
advance but uh but Wednesday like when
you're committing to doing the show
which I would have loved to have
committed to but it was like yeah it's
gonna be hard to cram like um minimum
it would have been like a minimum of
like 40 extra hours cramming for was it
10 episodes yeah yeah eight to ten yeah
and knowing like the way we edit and
stuff it would have taken it just I that
was the only reason why I skipped that
and by the time we get around to it you
know it's gonna be uh these people are
gonna move on to like oh [ __ ]
uh
it's probably
oh thank you river rock records that
means a lot film punch also congrats on
getting married thank you so much
thank you Spencer I appreciate it yeah
uh that's an interesting uh someone's
making a interesting comment about the
n-word all right fascinating
Venom Carnage thank you venom karner for
the Super Chat
2023 is going to start off with bangers
say The Last of Us um Defoe anticipating
and March alone there are four movies
Shazam scream ah cream
reunion John Wick four he's not dead I'm
excited to see that release within a
week of each other oh my God is within a
week of each other thick ass month time
to become shills for Rotten Tomatoes
paid critics here Greg and John go yeah
that's right we need those press screens
that's right otherwise how do we get in
we're just waiting for them to come out
and we'll react to them we could just
wait to react to them we I mean that's
that becomes the new thing is what do we
go to and then what do we wait to react
to in all of these movies I mean I feel
like we would have to see Shazam on the
biggest screen well if we have another
video that's like uh okay Zachary Levi
fired from Shazam
um then I'll wait for Shazam to come out
uh okay John Wick out of all of them
John Wick is easily the one that would
make for the best reaction and the one
you want to see the most on the pigs
cannot do that too I've seen all them in
the theaters yeah and I cannot break
tradition on that yeah I can't I feel
you I will just have to because no one
really gives a [ __ ] when we review a
John Wick movie I've noticed like what
we should just do a review don't really
it's like you're actually great yeah
stories is there and the same problems
that have persisted persist yeah but you
actually yeah and so obviously your
reaction would do better because you
could watch us and you react to the
fights yeah you can watch the moments
but I I think I have to stick to the
theaters for that one uh congrats on the
win and thank you again so much
six at home camera yeah
yeah I don't mind as much as screening
is my favorite horrible franchise I
would I I'm totally okay in this moment
I'm like yeah that's pretty much exactly
how I felt about Halloween ends I was
like you know what yeah now whatever I
don't care I'll watch it at home yeah I
don't I don't care for I mean I hope
it's great I hope Scream Six is great
but also like yeah you can watch that I
I like screen five I don't love it as
much as everyone else did and uh after
watching it twice I really stand by and
I watched it like
like months apart so you know I wanted
some time to just like let me separate
myself from any hype and I was like and
I said listen I have the exact same
opinion yeah
um is the Akira live action coming out
next year come on it would be cool to
react to that dude so I haven't seen
Akira I haven't seen Akira either one
time I got tickets
to a screening and I had to return them
jealous because we were covering the bad
batch
it was worth it
one day though I I'm dying to see Akira
they had they Kira slide in uh in nope
oh yes yes and you caught that John
please clean and cookie [ __ ] he he sent
us a Super Chat love the crew I love
that Christmas drip guys sorry I totally
threw this away from it I love I wanted
to check the I'll check has anyone could
uh we tend we're always like guys
contribute to the stream Labs it really
means a lot we appreciate it you take
less fees and then we constantly are
like oh yeah we should be checking if
people are sitting there even though
they take less fees and everything
November 12th no we haven't gotten any
new streamlabs yet oh because we can't
all right that's fine we're only on
Super Shots to stick with it I think
that's the case but either way I mean
let us know if you're having problems
Layton's
thank you if you're here please leave a
like it'll help us out for playback
later oh yeah and a comment if you would
uh Hey guys love the Christmas drip guys
just wondering what story lines and
characters you would love to see
rebooted in this DC uh what you would
love to see in this rebooted DC EU me
personally would love to see a robin I
feel like now is the time to do a robin
and there are many many thoughts about
this but I I was listening to a video
essay not long ago that really did
convince me that was like you know why
are these filmmakers and people seem so
opposed to Robin and uh and I think what
Robin does for Batman as a character is
actually overlooked and overrated
because you know it is that element of
like how do I then regain the humanity
in me and keep people from going down
the path I have gone down you know I
think Robin would be a great uh addition
in a real way and not just to like oh he
was here but now he's dead or something
like that kind of way yeah you know and
then when he does come time for you know
like a red hood type of story or
whatever else you know then you know you
got
I think the thing that's happened with
the DC Universe is you're it's really
easy to presume that James Gunn's like
fingerprints and DNA is going to be like
a hundred percent all over it when he's
simply just not going to be able to
he's gonna have to be a little bit more
like [ __ ] in the sense of like well I'm
making sure
like he will be I'm not saying he's not
going to be involved I think it's gonna
be more like a J.J Abrams level of
involvement where it is still going to
be letting the filmmaker shine and not
being like I'm definitely watching a
James Gunn movie because my mind went to
James going Robin I feel like he'd
probably do a bit of an Adrian Chase
thing that he did in Peacemaker and make
Robin like funny and goofy but cool
maybe he can still make him cool but
maybe take the piss out of him you know
um and so that's my one concern however
I'm like but that could actually work
for Robin I would like to see them get
to a Nightwing I think it would be
really cool if they did build to a bad
family yeah if Matt Reeves is not
attending if Matt Reeves does not have
an interest in building to a bad family
I would love to see James Gunn's side of
it build to a bad family because we
still haven't we haven't gotten that
executed properly
um outside of Batman and Robin
um that was which was amazing partners
Partners
[Laughter]
you did not miss a lot a wedding vlogger
footage uh nah that's I mean we've got a
lot of footage that's that's mainly for
personal yeah stuff to be honest thank
you for asking there's one part of the
wedding though during the vows that
Olivia said that totally surprised me
and if it brought the roof down yes if
there was a roof at this outside snowy
wedding
the roof would have come down it was it
was it was the funniest part of it I
might want to just isolate that and
share it like she she totally improvised
it too it is so funny
um yeah crack this up uh last of us I'm
very very excited for hearing great
things about it I know a lot of people
who got screeners for over no one of
them oh
uh acknowledge the Wednesday if you see
me scrolling this means I've already
like done that Kevin Shepard a good
first score sales move to watch oh I
think easily if you've never seen
Scorsese and you want to kind of see
what the hype is about and also prepare
you for what a Scorsese film is I think
undoubtedly Goodfellas is the one to to
go with because
every other one it's not a much of a as
much of a guarantee and many people who
hail Goodfellas as the best so it's not
like that I'll get work I think that's
an interesting thing about Scorsese is
that that's like the generally regarded
one as the best and most influential one
and I think you would see that at least
the most influential one just from that
one film and I think it still holds up
really well so I think if you haven't
seen this where it says you film you
want to get with the hype's about I
think Goodfellas is the is the best one
to go with and then I think even
exploring the other ones wouldn't make
you go what I start with the best one I
think it would actually help you
appreciate or kind of understand it
because it's like taxi drivers so
different from Goodfellas yeah and um or
even casino but his best ones tend to be
in the vein
Ensemble a lot of editing a lot of times
a lot of energy yeah yeah totally yeah
uh the Jon Snow series I don't know uh
we'll see uh iconic reaction I mean yeah
thank you iconic reactions means a lot
you thank you Pablo Ruiz I've seen a lot
of love here for a Marvel oh Marvel
Spider-Man
you guys think the Marvel trailer will
drop the Marvel oh the Marvels I'm
excited for the Marvels I'm excited to
to see some uh you know some leveling up
of that and maybe some additional love
from people for it sure I think when
that trailer actually comes out there is
going to be an impact and something cool
about seeing Kamala Khan
and Monica Rambo with like the two
characters who came from the TV yeah to
them be with Captain Marvel yeah one of
the movies I think there is gonna be
something really special because there
is there is kind of a really cool effect
when you do see like the movie character
that's that's part of the excitement I I
personally feel when you see Brie Larson
in that post credit scene for Miss
Marvel sure it's like the movie star
yeah yeah yeah yeah
and hopefully uh too you know whatever
niana Costa is able to do with her
Ensemble will bridge that Gap this is
listening to koi's Hero uh you know
ranking and I thought his point about
Brie Larson was apt that like yeah she's
got tons of Charisma and other things
and there's a lot about the role that
she is suited for but it doesn't quite
eat that Charisma into the role itself
and I hope that they can bridge that Gap
also see in Feliz Megan I am excited for
Megan I've heard Megan is pretty wild
see that's a reaction move that is a
reaction there was one yeah that's what
I'm like I will gladly wait for that to
come out to do a reaction for you
because they also do those video on
demand releases which so help out oh
yeah big big big crap in advance yeah
absolutely uh octar thank you for the
Super Chat Wes Anderson asteroid City
cast is out of the world pull it up all
righty let's do it pull it up ask oh
[ __ ] I know I've had the laptop here
this whole time so I can help out no I
have not been uh helping out you already
do so much it's got Margot Robbie and
Thomas Hanks really yeah Margot Robbie
and Tom Hanks and Scarlett Joe Robbie I
really I really love Margot she's
terrific she's
one of the few reasons I'm interested a
little bit tiny bit in Babylon
Steve Carell's in this room yeah dude
Tony revolory man you're lucky you got
him with that guy Brian Cranston
Cranston Rita Wilson too Sophia lillis
like because there's a lot of familiar
people who have worked with him a bunch
hongchap a lot of familiar people have
worked with them a bunch here but yeah
you don't open up the Wes Anderson and
go oh man he's working with uh
with uh Jason Schwartz
this is crazy
um oh yeah yeah star studded beyond the
what you'd already expected Jason I
don't know leave Schreiber not Dylan
Jeffrey Wright okay
yeah that is a massive cast people love
to be part of that Wes Anderson train
dude Jarvis Cocker from Pulp is going to
be in it I mean he sounds like one of
those filmmakers where even if you have
a tiny role you want to get that tiny
roll because you could probably be part
of the gang for a bigger role in a
follow follow a film yeah if you do well
enough and if you maybe steal like your
one scene then yeah you'll be in the in
the troop for life exactly yeah
let me see here there's gonna be a lot
of kids in this movie too so so many
great movies next year can't wait I
agree are you guys excited for Warrior
season three on HBO Max John is I love I
love Warriors
stop doesn't stop hey man
um
I'm gonna look into them I'm not sure
what that is
uh Ant-Man and the WASP quanta Mania
there's finally some love yeah
I'm excited for Ant-Man to to blow
people away finally
um let's see here
not a relevant question but I'd like to
eat what so anyone could talk to you but
I can set rules without pain something
because the villain Rancher interesting
Dan Trachtenberg for something X-Men and
Amber mid Thunder for x23 any thoughts
that would actually be a really cool
pick I would love I think I love that
Amber mid Thunder's work in
C and uh do you see you pray yeah in
Batman versus Predator it was great you
know I gotta see what this Super Chat is
that's how someone gave 100 from our
patreon I know we gotta see thank you
vampire such a generous don't it's such
a generous contribution donation dude
your money give more
[Laughter]
yeah it's only on stream Labs as well
yeah what are you doing you're stopping
at 100 keep going up here's each other
yeah hey guys thoughts on Elizabeth
Olsen's new HBO Mac Show Love and Death
uh but no robots not familiar with that
at all we just wanted to thank you guys
for all you do Inspire us to create our
own channel over 3K Subs now in less
than a year also big congrats to Greg
and Olivia well done fan pop you're on
better track than real rejects first
year only a thousand so in uh to get in
less than a year 3 000 subscribers
fantastic book keep it up fan pops
Boogie and I love Elizabeth Olsen's work
so I gotta see what this Love and Death
show is I have no familiarity with it
have you even heard of this I've never
even heard of this show not until this
morning when I was looking at upcoming
TV shows
I was like I know a lot of the upcoming
movies is there like trailers I haven't
seen anything for it I didn't see
nothing I don't know nothing G I love
the the Canon maggots uh he he's he's
going all um he's going all over the
place here with some fascinating
opinions
what's the most fascinating there's just
so much seemingly good content coming
next year I hope it all lives up to its
best potential I concur with these
statements if I just waited a tiny bit I
would have gone into the fan pops dude
right here fan pops the man thank you so
much fan pops uh Love and Death is a
David E Kelly series from like he did
the practice and various other things oh
and um and uh Donnie Darko and Donnie
that's that's right
J David E Richard Kelly
we were I watched uh Donnie Darko with
no no I watched Brazil with him in in
the audience he did a talk about it with
uh
with Edgar Wright oh really yeah oh nice
it was interesting raccoon shampoo
considering the suicide thank you for
the Super Chat by the way considering
the suicide squad do you think gns
gun and uh saffron yep I was trying to
think what movie is gns do you think
Goliath and Samson guns and sissies guns
and sissies that's a new movie waiting
to happen I like it guns and sissies
reunited
um the do you might lean into the R
ratings for DCU as a way to
differentiate it from the MCU
good I hope so I you know like there's
even though a lot of the talk is like
The Suicide Squad did not make that much
money and it didn't and it could have
done better for undoubtedly and while
they're often tends to be caught
caveats to the situation
it was one of those we're putting this
on HBO Max the same day and frankly you
know
as a movie like Godzilla versus Kong
being put on HBO Max same day makes more
sense to me whether that would be seen
in the theaters it's it's a Contin it's
a sequel continuing franchise and it's a
massive spectacle sure whereas The
Suicide Squad that the trailers just
don't like I I totally get why more
people would be like I'm just gonna wait
I'm just gonna watch the HBO Max yeah it
makes sense it makes perfect sense to me
well I think the theater experience was
was insanely Val I've actually never
re-watched at home I've seen it twice in
the theaters I loved it in the theaters
um there must be something to the actual
property that he made you know and I
think also how I think didn't we hear
the the talk about at one point about
James Gunn
possibly being like the person for Kevin
feige down the road who was supposed to
like help be the creative head of one
side of Marvel at some point I I think I
might have just Cosmic or something like
that it might have just been a rumor but
there was always that trust and faith in
him for that so
uh I think that with the suicide squad
that must have opened up some kind of
door for them to show like hey he can
introduce new characters here and make
it exciting because I think what they
paid attention to or maybe what zostla
paid attention to was the reception
because the reception to it while the
box office wasn't big the reception was
really huge and exhaust office keeps
touting you know
um making quality films and making it
more like that and so I think that with
him going down the r Raider route I
think that would help differentiate it
and
I think that would just be way cooler
yeah yeah I I would I personally would
love for them to go down the R-rated
route but you know that's something that
him and saffron discuss because I'm sure
saffron's the one who would be more
along the lines to go
this one should not be R-rated like if
we do R-rated that would be bad this one
would benefit from being R-rated and
will probably do better like I think
there is an argument to be made for
sometimes a film will make more money if
it is R-rated and I think the the common
general knowledge is if you make it
PG-13 more people can watch it it'll be
I'm like but no not necessarily I think
depending on the film if it is R-rated
it'll actually make more money sure yeah
yeah yeah if if it appears that you are
doing this character Justice we are out
of focus what is happening John it's
wrong everything's wrong get that auto
focus working John there we go it's back
okay was Logan Logan was rated R right
yeah yeah I can't remember if it was
Logan or Deadpool but I believe James
Gunn himself had put out a tweet thread
at the time that like the opening
weekend of one of those movies at least
where he was saying like you know this
weekend this movie came out we're all
excited to see it do well and what's
gonna happen and now is a bunch of
Studio heads are going to take the wrong
lesson from this and start harvesting
and looking for what's the next
irreverent R-rated movie we can do
without really looking and seeing
whether or not that suits the project or
whether or not you know like that's the
exact right kind of theory to go off of
they're looking at this as like bullet
points and stuff yeah so with with a
comment like that I would imagine that
sure I think the DCU going forward will
have much more carte blanche to go
R-rated when they think it's appropriate
but I don't think especially as compared
to Marvel uh but I don't think that they
will just be like yeah make everything
rated R I don't think that's the right
spiritual choice to make and I think
they are clever enough to know that
that's the case and I think they are
smart enough to know that even though
R-rated superhero movies are exciting
superhero movies are also for all
audiences and I think they would be
foolish to just be like nah no kids over
here you know yeah so yeah we'll get
some but probably not all of them
R-rated Superman too many penis jokes
he's just lasering penises like yeah
he's lasering dicks have you seen that
uh have you seen that video Corridor
crew broke it down on their website at
one point where RoboCop it's the scene
in the alleyway with the girl where he
shoots the guy in the crotch except
except it's just like tons and tons of
guys keep showing up and they all at
least RoboCop just shooting off dick
uh yeah it's it's it's uh I'm not it's
very graphic and very amusing sounds
like you ruined the joke it doesn't
matter I watch it it doesn't matter
you you'll be entertained uh yes hey YJ
there's your Shadow Jessica Cohen stop
by to say hey but uh dipped out because
of spoilers oh what's what's spoilers
we're talking about upcoming potential
spoilers what what what about we haven't
talked about anything any spoilers I
don't think back house Kelly Merry
Christmas to you too absolutely a new
Disney musical always excited for a new
Disney musical Dakota Jones John
Carpenter should definitely do a dead
space movie I feel like that's the one
thing he would be passionate about
making right now
uh Quentin Marcus top five games you
played well one of our top Super
Chatters here I would say that uh top
five game honestly the last of us too is
going to be the most controversial thing
I say this whole stream uh the last of
us too is my all-time favorite video
game we used to be Metal Gear Solid
three but I would say last of us too and
I know that's a controversial loss
opinion
but nope that's my favorite game played
both of them back to back uh last year
and I was like yep I love this game it's
my favorite one yeah it just speaks to
me man speaks to me top five uh Resident
Evil the remake for GameCube uh Metal
Gear Solid three yeah Star Fox 64. uh
you know
resistance fall of Man yeah and uh
summons no we lost our spot gold darn it
we lost our spot could you
we tried to We Trust his ghosts in order
today and then this shit's got messed up
oh no
where are we jack who are we just
reading oh wait I think I'm there no I'm
not there you're not there but it's okay
it's good I like to convert these live
streams and we'd like to convert these
into podcasts okay so we were oh no
we're right around here we're actually
we're definitely here yeah yeah
um now let's see here seen some opinions
about the gun
big fan from Bangladesh thank you so
much Merry holidays to you Robert that's
well you know that flash movie better be
amazing I'm just saying
I I I don't even know how to feel about
that movie anymore it's it's like it's
it's it's gone completely circle in my
mind and now I'm just kind of like yeah
I'll see it when I see it
zombie man of course secret war is gonna
sell out like crazy dude of course of
course
oh yeah yeah dude Marvel fatigue will be
nothing when Secret Wars drops it's
interesting like I think what gun's
doing right now with DC is actually
smart because like they're getting all
the drama out of the way yeah it's that
way they can make the create
anticipation for when the projects are
actually announced
you know it's just kind of like get the
drama out of the way get the pain out of
the way like like start the breakup
process it is what he's doing you know
um so I I think it's going to be a
fascinating year but then Marvel's they
got some great I mean [ __ ] Deadpool
3's coming 2024 but still Deadpool
threes hey it's on the horizon returning
man that's gonna be gnarly uh Daniel
Dune gutted we didn't review AMC's
Pantheon it was awesome sorry you're the
first person I and only person I know
who's mentioned what is that what's his
Pantheon please enlighten me uh we might
do I I'm holding on off in this question
top five moves from this year because we
might do like a top movies of 2012
that's why I'm trying to watch the whale
and squeezing Northman uh because
um I'm trying to I want to be able to
maybe do a live stream next week where
we talk about that cool
love from India thank you
thank you for the congrats on the
wedding Andy
Harry nice to see you here Daniel oh
Salazar Salazar
what's up from Miami happy holidays guys
racist various racism that's so racist
man that's racist they say they're
[ __ ] Cuban over there sorry hold on
happy holidays from Miami with all my
cocaine and aviator glasses and my white
white suit happy holidays guys thank you
for the amazing content and always
amazing reactions thank you for the
amazing comment and support and love
thank you thank you so much thank you
Daniel Salazar that sounds like a man
from Miami for sure do non-racist
commentary Daniel Salazar sounds like a
guy you don't want to mess with but you
want to be friends with River Rock
Records have you seen Loki's life
because you clearly see that he can make
doubles of himself he must have been
getting into an argument with someone
here oh yeah yeah river rock records has
been the subject of many a comment oh
really and apparently devotion was kind
of mad very bad that's bummer I mean how
bad has it gotten uh I haven't seen
anything that that seems like outright
offensive but then again I've only seen
it like once or twice so I think even if
you say something that's just slightly
irk someone you deserve to be banned
from our chat yeah of course never does
that don't worry your comments will
still show up in this section on the
stream where it says show or hide so
it'll still be seen yeah we'll see it
and you guys will see it on the screen
yeah it doesn't really matter
you just can't directly respond tmn have
you guys seen the new Ellis movie it is
really good I have seen the new Elvis
movies this movie I liked it
what's your opinion this won't work uh I
like it would have worked as a reaction
it just would have been a lot of
copyright crazy ass music
from like 30 copyright claims though all
right I won't write off any music based
movies now okay ready for that Knight's
tail reaction let's do it you haven't
seen a knight's style never
well D noise I'll unmute all the songs
yeah really ruin the experience for you
where were we the Elvis movie yeah I
liked Elvis uh quite quite a bit I mean
I I feel like it is it is that sort of
coked out experience and I kind of got
what you meant it was like the first
half is like whoa whoa whoa and then and
then it eases into itself and I didn't
even dislike Tom Hanks the way a lot of
other people did like I was like they're
I'm sure there was a more suitable
casting however I'm still enjoying
watching this odd caricature portrayal
like it it didn't feel quite as
disconnected from everything as I was
led to believe I never only saw the
character sure absolutely I've always
always where I'm watching Tom Hanks dude
like he's doing good in my opinion but
I'm I'm also not lost in it yes
especially when you have a
such a powerful performance like Austin
Butler yeah who is phenomenal on that
phone is yeah I cry I didn't know most
of Elvis's story okay I I cried
um at that
um I don't remember the plot points
and it is like an onslaught of a movie
too it is one of those ones where even
when you see it once you feel like you
lived through some kind of hallucinatory
fever dream and you're like to get the
finest points I would need to go back
there's just something boss Lerman has
that thing where it's just like nothing
leaves this movie yes there is no
Cutting Room floor it's all lost
on in some way yeah totally no footage
gets like unused but yeah about like 30
40 minutes in or something like that it
really started mesh for me I really had
no idea
you know you always assume that every
one of these people has some type of
tragic life story but I was like wow I
didn't realize Elvis was robbed of his
money so much
and he couldn't manage to this guy he's
so legendary he's like the one of the
biggest artists of all time
and to know that he did not get access
to that one like
yes that's insane to me that that is
such a like I was watching it it was one
of those experiences where I went home
right away I'm like what is true yeah
yeah right what is the uh fact versus
fiction here I had to know um well and
Sarah William just said now I know Elvis
hated being in all those beach movies he
made I think he felt them to be useless
and stupid at the same time but have you
guys um seen Austin Butler on SNL he has
a a nice he acknowledges the fact that
his voice has changed
and he calls himself or Elvis now he had
uh he had a good opening he had a good
monologue but there was this
there's this spoof
sketch about it's got like a kind of
like a spoof on like it's a wonderful
life I don't want to give it away okay
but it's basically a spoof on like those
like
1930s Christmas black black and white
it's it's such a simple sketch but it is
so funny it is it is a great sketch I
really liked it a lot I'm glad to hear
it guys leave a like that mean a lot
leave that like
um let's see here YouTube know that you
like us you really like us ah back house
Kelly gave you plenty of movie
recommendations good to know appreciate
it thank you back house upcoming CG up
to the front house uh I have heard of
this movie it's the Adam Driver film
haven't seen the trailer
65 but once I heard Adam Driver Dino
I went probably gonna react to this
movie Adam Driver don't need to watch
her Rock Let's Do It
there's a guy I found on the Instagram
who does good Impressions and one of the
Impressions he does is Adam Driver and I
was impressed because I was like it's
not the most obvious impression I could
see definitely see he's got a very
distinct delivery and Cadence and yeah
once you once you see it happen you're
like oh yeah okay yeah in my opinion
Adam Driver also one of the best SNL
hosts of all time he is he like both
times I think he's supposed to twice
he's hysterical oh yeah like he's so
[ __ ] funny and very well it's crazy
because he's known as like this like
really serious dramatic actor yeah but
he he is he is so and he takes that
level of commitment and he understands
the comedy because I knew Adam Driver
from girls that's where I Associated
Adam Driver was the guy from girls for
so long yeah but then after like kylo
like it's it's crazy how much he's
transformed his career you know the male
lead from Girls the one with the
blossoming
um what was he like on that show as a
character what kind of guy does he play
does he play an uh the kind of character
you would associate Adam Driver with now
no okay gotcha
yeah he's kind of like a relatable dude
artiste kind of character okay but he's
great he was great in that show
definitely accepting a lot of us take on
dinos sexual scenes you could watch that
oh but yeah Serena Cuevas thank you so
much Serena thank you for the Super Chat
uh anyone who's contributed to Super
chess thank you so much been watching
for all y'all for years and you guys are
the best congrats in the wedding Greg it
looked beautiful it was it was also like
10 degrees it was cold worth it but it
was good pictures and video Lagoon it
was beautiful thank you so much cold was
beautiful too
um Daniel would you want Jordan peel to
do an MCU movie yes sure I would love to
see that probably more of a d I actually
with James Gunn I'd probably want to see
him do a DC film I feel like I had more
creative Reign sure yeah yes absolutely
I feel like he could easily do a good
Marvel but yeah the DC would be more of
a peeled joint
that's your Excel you guys are my
favorite reaction review channel oh
thank you very much send that message to
Blind wave specifically them yes the
real reason and then find a channel that
only has like 5 000 subscribers and send
that to them too yeah really really
discouraged yeah when they need it the
most
dude thank you Kevin
hi freeze thank you for the uh
it's a plum a plum yeah what's atsp I
don't know okay let's see here atsv I
I've heard that acronym what's your
least anticipated movie Next Year great
question
uh The Hunger Games pretty cool I have
no interest in seeing that film uh also
watches I would love to be pleasantly
surprised by the trailer
sure husband
Olivia you gotta change your last name
here
oh yeah dude you now you're owned by the
Alba so you gotta have his last name on
you bully McGuire Greg were you and it's
always sunny
no Does this answer your question what
is he like 40. oh dude it's the line I
want to pitch a a spec script too it's
always sunny sure where my character kid
number two it comes back comes back and
uh finally
I've become
a a a like uh
a very successful businessman because I
witnessed these uh adults partying with
a bunch of high schoolers and wasting
their lives away
inspired me yeah
yeah that's awesome that would be a
great story too and imagine if one day
you get to be on their podcast
um I I want to pitch a spec script for
It's Always Sunny a real specs group
will want to pitch actually I just like
to see it be made I don't care if
someone else pitches it it does it I I
would love it I just want to see you get
made is uh the game gets rebooted
yes or it really you know like they
recast themselves and stuff they're like
we're gonna die one day yeah we're gonna
hand off patties
yeah I think it would be a perfect
perfect It's Always Sunny episode I
would love to I'm a big It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia fan Dennis and Mac
just bickering over who people are
choosing to be them because they don't
see it and then Charlie has a choice he
just really wants to push through and
everyone's like no Charlie you can't be
a black guy yeah yeah
um Dead The Last of Us getting a lot of
I'm soaks after the last of us
um the Marvels gain some love can't wait
for knocking The Cabin in the Woods
that's right that movie is showing on
that's a reaction that's a reaction
movie Sometimes everywhere
before people watch the reaction instead
like uh sometimes I just like doing the
reviews but you know sort of knocking
cam Woods I'm like people might not even
watch your reaction
I'd be more worth it in the end
Jimmy wise the joking clown did you hear
Johnny Depp is back in business and do
you care of course I do
no I don't really care seems like he's
been enjoying himself you don't really
care that Johnny Depp's back in business
I don't want to think about Johnny Depp
for a while I just don't want to think
about him I don't know when I think
about him I want to go to Amber page and
yell at her that's right that's Amber
page Amber page what's your last thing
I've ever heard I completely forgot it
it's okay whatever Queen mirror it's
good uh you know he's uh I saw a video
of him as Captain Jack uh recently doing
one of those charitable uh you know
appearances it was cool but I'm just
like I don't know I want the taste out
of my mouth for a little while before
I'm like hey he's back I would love it
if he's just getting laid left and right
he is you know it's happening yeah
might as well take advantage they ruled
me innocent let's do this yeah you got
to be smart though you could just be
sleeping around with people sure he can
as long as he's being ethical about it
yeah he absolutely could be
because now he's more popular yeah every
woman out there wants to come in and be
like what she did to you I will never do
that
I will fix you
it'll work on me too when I meet him
sure
um we all we'll all cuddle Johnny Sky
next to oh my God uh Happy Birthday to
You Skye happy birthday
happy birthday it's copyright Happy
non-copyrighted Birthday song about you
what what's both your most anticipated
movie aside from Barbie I weirdly is not
my favorite trailer hmm it does not look
like the best movie of the year to me it
doesn't
I weirdly have Indiana Jones 5 on my
list though as my most anticipated yeah
that's the one I'm just so curious to
see if they pull it off
better like can it be as great as
um you know like one or three and and
and
will Doom [ __ ] take back anything he
said will he grow oh if only yeah
Indiana Jones is definitely high up on
that list I have actual sort of Hope do
you have an actual possible number one
first one that Springs to mind the one I
have a real answer okay the the real not
like this but this also and this also
maybe but maybe that one too all right
fine then I'll I will be on brand and I
will say that I um
I'm a sucker and I'm excited for saw 10.
I'm just I'm gonna there you go there
final saw is coming back I will finally
the truth John Kramer Tobin Bell will be
in it like as much as I was here for
Chris Rock saw and would have watched
more spiral movies I'm like yes I I
cannot wait for the return of John
Kramer so that and an evil dead rise are
pretty naked Nick oh my God the Avatar
pitch meeting is out we have thank you I
would love to do it yeah
I'd love to just end this stream not
read anyone else's super chess that we
have not gotten to yeah like sorry guys
whatever pitch meeting time is of the
essence right now this comedic films
Gotta Laugh at Ryan George yeah gotta
find a way to comment and embellish his
video
my most anticipated film next year from
Dragon Soldier thank you for the Super
Chat yes I gave a generous contribution
to Chris stuckman's Shelby Oaks I'm very
excited for it man
um I'm hoping that
uh a homogeneous messaged him you should
be like hey can I go to one of your
screenings
I think my my Kickstarter package
actually bless you allows me to go to
one of your screenings but I would love
to be able to go and distract and try to
take all the attention away from you try
to get everyone talking to me yeah
record your reaction during the movie
yeah I would love to I would love to I I
can't wait I forgot that that is a I
mean I never but the film like his it
might not it gets done in a while
putting assembling it that it could come
out 2024. yeah but um if it comes out
2023 yeah I'm very excited for it that'd
be amazing if the be such a fascinating
journey of you know like like someone
like Bo Burnham his the way he's
transitioned he doesn't like document
the the journey in a way that's just
constantly letting people in on it yeah
whereas Chris stuckman has taken the
path of I'm not trying to do this behind
it's like I have stuff that I'm working
on that I'm not talking to anybody about
publicly you know I'm doing
he's done so there's like more there's
more eyes on him there's more there's
more pressure on him to deliver so
I I think he would give his best effort
like I regardless of how the film turns
out even if I end up like not liking it
myself I I have a hard time believing
I'm gonna walk away going that doesn't
look like this man put his best work in
here though oh no of course not yeah no
I'm excited to see what he comes up with
because uh even just following along
with his little updates like it seems
like he's very passionate and like
definitely definitely I mean getting
some creepy stuff on on tape so
I would love like I can't wait to see it
love to see you
um Andrew Kelly thank you Andrew excited
for Creed Three finally some love for
Creed Three especially with Jonathan
majas yes how's that Jonathan major and
also it's uh uh Michael B Jordan's
correct Jordan
directorial debut that's right man
Michael B Jordan it's gonna be a sexy
experience it's gonna be so hot it's
gonna be the most buff movie ever
this is good he was a good cyborg too I
liked him in uh in uh
in Flashpoint
Michael B Jordan with cyborg he was
Cyborg he was Victor Stone did not know
that he was the one voice who who I was
like I'm pretty sure I know who that
voice is I did not know that once you
have if you hear it again you'll you'll
definitely immediately be like oh damn
yeah uh let's see here my wedding was
last weekend yes Eon blush thank you so
much John take it away I don't know if
y'all listen to juice world but recently
I've been watching Moon Knight again and
y'all should listen to In My Head by
juice world because that is the perfect
song for Marvel's Moonlight you should
do I've heard some juice world I haven't
heard this particular juice World joint
rest in peace juice world but what you
should do is you should make one of
those YouTube videos where someone takes
a popular song and then like does a
super cut of like a bunch of moon night
moments saying this song that
thematically fits the themes of the show
you should do that
um and then we will both listen to it
there is
let me try to find the song here because
because I've been wanting to do one is
just be very very time consuming and
unmonetizable yeah that's a waste of
Creative Energy
[Laughter]
definitively uh the the the band is
called the score ooh cool what is the
name of this song
I think this song is called stronger
okay and I wanted to do one for Henry
cavill's Superman oh cool yeah that is
when I wanted to do it would get
traction and blocked for use of song
that would because you can't just you
know
to denoise it
yeah see clown Prince crime you get it
man you the bat family very important
Sean C thank you so much Sean C John is
a big fan of YouTuber Chauncey that's
right
um like thank you for the appreciation
uh comment that means a lot thank you
it's always nice to have a new person on
board but the reject Nation show enough
welcome aboard the flash is my most
anticipated DCU project hope to get the
chair by latest January oh these come in
February I think that was like
officially unveiled it's coming February
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we'll have to see a movie together in
2023
uh Marvel just I think Marvel I think
when Ant-Man the Lost Corner Mania kills
it you know it's gonna be good uh it's
gonna be good absolutely not excited for
Scream Six without Sydney I'm curious to
see if they can pull it off I am too I
mean I guess
I guess part of me then goes my first
first movie Crush I know Sydney Prescott
see part of me goes like I wish at this
point they wouldn't even bring back Gail
like they would almost like relieve
themselves for an installment of having
to incorporate Legacy characters but uh
yeah I'm not I'm sad at the
circumstances however you know in the
previous Instagram five she wasn't like
the most vital character in how they
used her so you know it's more of a
bummer of like yeah scream I love seeing
Neve Campbell be Sydney but but at the
same time hey you know go go do your
thing and see how that goes I really
hated the whole thing with Billy Loomis
and uh
and and like the imagination of Billy
Loomis I thought that was a strangely
handled mode I hated it and I I think
they should bring it back though with
Dewey
yes oh do it ghost Dewey I want it I
want ghosts do we make it happen that's
one of the things that I think really
lacks in in that film like I have a lot
of issues with Scream five but wait with
something with Dewey or something with
that no I think Dewey's death is
powerful and you get like a minute of
Courtney coxby like yeah and yeah she
gets to kill the one who did it but it
it doesn't feel like a personal Revenge
Conquest in that moment sure just like
we gotta do I think we gotta kill them
yeah I'm like that's the [ __ ] love of
your life yeah I made so much
really bothers me yeah they made so much
of the lingering you know threads of
your relationship too in them yeah so
yeah I I did not like how I have a lot
of issues with that movie uh Alex see
wow just stumble on this will happen if
we're happy for you to be here welcome
hiya right Back at Ya
um it was a great year for for movies
every movie was great including
Uncharted with Tom Holland the lead
actresses pose is the image of the Mona
Lisa oh really I did not catch that in
Glass Onion oh wow
Ah that's fun
um I like your taste here Megan knock at
the Cow ones I'm in three there's
apparently an Insidious five coming out
too which I'm excited for isn't Patrick
Warburton Wilson uh directorius I'm here
to look at some ghosts
Patrick Wilson yes uh give me he's gonna
be naked in the director's chair he's
gonna have James Juan produce it so he
knows what he's doing yeah yeah James
can you can you like this shot what
would you do in this situation James
okay uh coin to do that Quentin Anthony
Anderson thank you again buddy curious
where I never got a ration of the
cocaine bearer of violent Night trailer
soon right after Allen their actions
would be awesome well we'll probably
cover the movie so don't you don't you
fret on a violent night just dropped on
VOD
um no yeah we just didn't
um do it there was something else
happening sometimes it's just happening
in the day and then we're caught up with
something else especially like working
on the movie reactions those those are
very they they take to consume time they
can consume a good amount of time so you
know sometimes it's just like all right
it's not going to do this right now
because don't worry Robin West Parker
the gun averse will be your retribution
the gun saffron verse you're asking me
Quentin if I've seen high top films
video essays I'm a massive fan of high
top films videos you interact with that
uh I've talked to him quite a bit on uh
social media before he's [ __ ] awesome
have you seen high top films video
essays they are all very in-depth and
written great I call myself pretentious
to alleviate anything of anyone calling
me pretentious in my videos but I am a
passionate speaker and then I and
on a more poignant delivery
it's like he's here in the room it's
good pandemic Jones
love you buddy I love how you made a
comedy on blush and then you you put it
in the Super Chat then you put it here
again
um let's see here
film Theory it's shaking time
well Mario becomes his full self in the
upcoming Mario movie his Chris Pratt
voice disappears and you'll be
transformed into the original Mario with
his original Mario voice
that would be interesting it'd be like
the frames of Grindelwald sure yeah this
guy just became a totally different guy
yeah and that's who he really is and a
very different voice actor Anthony yeah
sure why not it's a me is this true that
is weird if Adamson wants to continue
his Batman he requested on no other
properties coming to his journey so to
speak other than Zoe Kravitz as Selena
again
yeah I I would want that I could see
that and I I James Gunn has shouted out
Matt Reeves as a filmmaker in other like
interviews before he took over
and I think he he would want Mata Reeves
Batman to be separate I I feel like he
'd support that everyone I don't know
everything's surprising me these days I
I don't know yeah unless they really
tool the universe into just being that
aesthetic all overall but yeah I feel
like everyone is seems smart enough to
know that the charm of that is that it
has its own universe and it doesn't need
to be tainted by a lot of other
clashing tones
uh Disney movies like Elemental and wish
yes I wanna I can't wait for those what
if elements had feelings Elemental
element of elements that feelings yeah
uh what's the best James Cameron movie
The Abyss uh teeth what's the worst
James Cameron movie Piranha two piranha
two that's probably it damn beat me to
it it's gonna be someone in here who's
got a special place it's Avatar one and
two
um
one might argue that Avatar is the thing
that that destroyed the James Cameron
that we know but he's always been a
technological innovator yeah
and I mean I don't know like I I feel
like uh
I don't feel like you could argue that
the same way you could argue like seeds
you gotta ruin Tim Burton you know like
I feel like there's a much easier
argument to make there's more I mean CGI
made it easier for Tim Bergen where as
James Cameron uh is purposeful yeah very
very purposeful and has never content
with what's available here and now yeah
I love it yeah yeah we did read this one
from eon eon
it's okay though we gotta get that juice
world you gotta do that super cut man
hashtag I've seen a good amount of uh of
uh Castlevania it's awesome oh cool uh
aviro Greg what'd you think of a
spectacular Spider-Man himself being
confirmed for across a spider verse John
do a spectacular reaction
dude you know what I might uh I might
assign such a case I would love that uh
I I do really I think Spectacular
Spider-Man it pains me the way because
it it it doesn't conclude
because it got canceled because of
Oilers because of I don't know something
like it wasn't like it had nothing to do
with lack of views it was something with
with the merger hap I think it was a
merger or or property it might not have
been the merge some business [ __ ] and
and so it didn't get to properly end and
it it really bums me out and it would be
cool if across the spider verse decided
to like throw in a few lines just to
alleviate that yeah um
I would love that but yeah because
that's that was the biggest promise I
loved Spectacular Spider-Man I I I loved
that that was such an easy cartoon to
get into Rosa para in the chat hey Rosa
holding it down seeing all the films all
the cinema I love I've loved catching
your thoughts yeah you are a prolific
cinephile and I admire that okay
psych for more Severance I still haven't
seen Severance everyone loves that show
I still haven't seen it
Brian Johnson been enjoying my movie
watch thank you
dude's got a show coming out with
Natasha Leone in 2023 I'm excited to see
Bucky Barnes thank you Bucky for being
who you are yeah put some respect on
Scott Lang uh let's see I thank you for
the Super Chat movie Guardians of Galaxy
vol 3 show Ahsoka those are good ones
those good choices
looking forward to those as well
um let's see here Jane and the Autobots
hey Jane uh speaking of warrior how do
we request you to finally watch Tom
Hardy's Warrior yeah John what are you
getting to that dude what are you
finally gonna watch Tom Hardy's Warrior
several years ago at a test screening
yeah I remember that yeah I remember you
telling me about it yeah it was good I
was surprised people like went as nuts
for the movie as they did but it was
good I liked it yeah I only saw like the
first few minutes it's good it's a good
movie and uh I didn't get to finish it I
don't know how literally I saw the first
few minutes I remember something about
Joel Edgerton being poor sure is he poor
am I wrong about that I think college is
more like the upright yeah he's the more
I think it was a suit or something
black sheep of the family yeah
like the cool one yeah and then there's
Nick Nolte who's his dad was the dad of
them both playing reprising his role
from Hulk yeah
looking like he's gonna die every frame
yeah yeah
um I would love to react to it though
because I literally don't even remember
the [ __ ] I saw good movie uh but yeah I
would love to it's very emotional it's a
guy crying I'm assuming it it leads to
the brothers fighting each other in the
end uh because I don't want to spoil
anything for you I've seen the image
where like from ever ago where like they
have arms around each other after the
fight but I'm like
that's the problem with me now you know
it's like now now I'm at this point in
my in my career
as I call it here
I call this my career
it is it is in many ways it's your
Enterprise it's your Empire that if I
don't cry to certain thing people are
like
disappointed you didn't cry at that you
didn't engage with the peace gotta say
oh
man
I'm not on a soap opera where I'm
commanded to cry
I don't feel like crying I'm just not
gonna cry yeah you should cry always
even when it's inappropriate then people
really start tuning in they're like what
is this guy gonna cry about next hey
Greg since you just watched uh Princess
and the Frog I heard that Matt brings
Connor's restaurant to the Disney
grounds what do you think I heard that I
heard they're changing one of the rides
The Princess and the Frog Splash
Mountain because Splash Mountain's
racist Song of the South is
racism like who's who's who's the black
one the putter but yeah let's do that
one we're not racist which movie we've
got us for not being racist which movie
most cost efficiently lends itself to
repurposing this yeah look at us it's
the Frog but I'm excited I like white
men we have made the right decision here
we have elevated people of color at
Disneyland yes and our job is done
fixing racism I really like the
character Tiana a lot though I thought
she was I like the character more of
Tiana than I do the actual movie
um
yeah especially because she was like
independent and go oriented and
motivated and yeah set out to be uh like
a like makeup business for herself like
this is a cool especially for a female
character it's a cool character to have
in a Disney movie it's not just like I
want a man yeah and happening before the
time where everyone was like you know
had their hackles raised about
incorporating that kind of character in
the first place like I feel like it gets
to be a little more genuine in that
Pursuit because of being ahead of the
focal point of that conversation I mean
like don't get me wrong like you got
characters like I saw Moana recently you
got characters like Moana who's very you
know much her own like literally no
interest in being a princess or nothing
about a man at all and and I think
that's really cool and and but there's
but this is something just like
relatable and grounded because we all
see that with so many like male
portrayals of like the man wanting to
make a name for himself in a career and
stuff like career driven and to get that
from uh the female perspective and
classic Disney animated film Matt I
thought was refreshing that that was a
refreshing experience to me Stephen
Jenkins thank you for the Super Chat
Jinx thank you so much theoretically
hear me out here if you're attacked by
an infinite number of rabid Penguins
John yeah getting released in swarms of
10 every 15 seconds
how many could you beat before they kill
you did this for research 10 every 15
seconds
how many could you beat before they kill
you
infinite number of rabid penguins
I mean do I have a weapon
uh I suggest my hands and feet I think
even with my own hands and feet I don't
think a single one of them could uh lay
a little lay a single one land a single
one on me I mean I think I can kick a
penguin's ass yeah you could probably do
a lot of sweeping and a lot of Kicking
and a lot of you know I've fought many a
penguin before many one-on-one cage
fights yeah and yeah the way of Liam
Neeson versus wolves I do that often in
the Antarctic with penguins
and uh I gotta save my penguins got
nothing I can go through like the whole
fields of them yeah mow them down ten
thousand Penguins I don't care it
doesn't matter Morgan Freeman's
narrating take me down my ass whooping
I'm delivering that's right
as the fist connects with the bill of
the penguin
foreign what do you guys think how many
penguins could you take out uh Bucky
Barnes subscriber to Fan pops that's
what I like to hear hey I would love to
watch Ted lasso Ronaldo do it and be
reminded of him and Olivia Wilde's
ongoing divorce okay yeah oh you'll be
just in time for the new season in 2023.
what a nasty public divorce ugh
um might as well turn into a reality
show Cafe tomorrow the boy season four
is coming no one's talking enough about
that yes the boy season four cannot wait
back Jensen
yeah bring we demand we bring that
Jensen why aren't you guys doing this
soldier boy are you excited for Gen V
kind of I think Amazon did a terrible
job promoting just a little bit all they
had to do was say the boys spit off in
their title oh my God it was so much
more attention the boys Generation V
yeah
or gen V the boy or something like that
yeah something where it's obvious yeah
yeah to people who aren't plugged into
this yeah yeah yeah because my first
thought when I heard gen V I'm like some
weird young adult show
yeah that's right yeah yeah I had no I
didn't the only reason I knew gen V was
because I heard about it you know yeah
that making movie looks corny so goddamn
right is the rumor about Carl from
Walking Dead being the next Superman
real I'm too lazy to research I don't
know I don't know I'm sure I want that
Chandler Riggs
let's see let's find that
or how about Kyle Chandler Kyle Chandler
would be a fine this would be a good
person
actually wasn't he a podcast was he in
that breitburn movie no no no that was
Roy from the opposite yeah yeah yeah
okay Chandler Riggs Superman Coral
dude are they ever gonna race
uh to voice Superman in RWBY Justice
League crossover I would love to see
Austin Butler play Superman with his Now
accent sure
Paul I need to go save those people low
is a low dude interview with you
dude this is crazy
what hell of a photographer I'm gonna
take my picture I'm a fish photographer
now
yes yes I agree Sarah Williamson thanks
pandemic I like the way we're doing the
stream too very nonchalant
yeah and I like that idea about a a
Mandela effect movie that would be cool
Joshua toffee thanks for the Super Chat
as a field being a married man Greg it
feels like all the ladies pining over
Greg I'm gonna have to
redirect the traffic lane to John
because we all know that's how it goes
around here
ladies like ladies please ah too much I
used to say yes to all but I'm married
now so if you just follow the signs
you know this door it's raining yeah
catch John over there waiting in
terminal 5B for real ladies hey that's
right come find me at the airport I will
get you there I will have you Soaring
Over California
that's right that's how it goes here
it's reject Nation my rear thank you for
the Super Chat there Robert Eggers doing
a Nosferatu film yes he is what I am
jacked for that yeah oh my God is that
coming out I've never been more excited
for uh remake in my life yeah who's in
that isn't it isn't it Bill Skarsgard or
something Willem Dafoe
probably as the shadow of the vampires
let's get it going it's just the same
castle and John Malkovich
uh Bill Skarsgard Lily Rose Depp and
Robert Eggers
Lily Rose Depp really yeah is he gonna
set it in New England hopefully
please it's gonna be in Maine
or a Rhode Island oh that that's awesome
oh my God and it's not going to be at
all what people expect yeah Bill
Skarsgard is not for out too because it
seems like he does warlock seems like
he'd kill Skarsgard really
yeah which is what the [ __ ] which is
like come on I'm so sorry I'm starting
to get I get it it's like the the new
Christoph Waltz yeah sure
who's like the most obvious creepy actor
you can play for him yeah and it's like
I mean not to say too much but you know
like part of so much of the charm of
something like barbarian was like okay
they got that they they knew that you
know whereas here I'm like okay so we're
gonna see him play another pale I love
that pale evil character that is
definitely one of my favorite movies of
the Year absolutely there's lots of
people who really don't like that movie
yeah I love it
um I mean I think Barbarian is easily
one of the top and and like I like
really I know what my number one is sure
I I I'm far and away undoubtedly know my
number one I think we're on the same
page of that yeah we might yeah really I
think we are too probably yeah easily my
number one but but barbarian was
definitely close to the top and I mean
like people love smile but I I much
preferred Barbarian over that
it's much more uh yeah it's weird
because they're both kind of doing
things that have been done but Barbarian
felt like like locked in and fresh and
rollicking the whole time no man yeah I
I always prefer roberry yeah I don't
even consider her smile as like top 10
well that was one where we saw and I was
like okay I get why this is popular I
really like what's really good I get
what's good about it but on the whole I
definitely don't appreciate this as much
yeah it is doing a lot more just sort of
like yeah I've seen this and it's just
lucky that this is good and it's
focusing on the right thing that
respects smile a lot yeah like I I love
the act and and there's some truly scary
moments there are but yeah yeah it's a
good Blockbuster horror movie
yes I that I would categorize it there
but we are um
more elevated than that job that's right
we are babadook we are a little bit more
above we're a higher tier than we are
elevated horror people consumers
everyone's favorite turn of phrase
it does sound like such a demeaning word
elevated yeah as because the rest of it
is low bro it sounds like it is a it is
who who is the one who said they don't
like using that terms there was a
director recently who said they don't
like saying elevated horror it might
have been the Barbarian director yeah
sure
um and I and I agreed with that I'm like
it does sound like
it sounds like higher than yeah it's a
different kind of horror yeah you know
and I'm like they weren't [ __ ] saying
that when movies like shining and
Exorcist came out yeah yeah this is
elevated horror you know yeah it's just
there they have more dramatic elements
than this is an elevated comedy
that's right
you know that we call a Coen brothers
comedy yeah yeah this is a comedy for
sophistic kids yeah otherwise you will
not enjoy hail Caesar
you won't like burn after real yeah or
Intolerable Cruelty
um cinematic goodness thank you for the
Super Chat
congrats on the wedding
congrats to you too congratulations
this may be um unrelated
but
since you've been on a Disney kick with
those reactions any movies you haven't
seen that you're excited curious about
to reacting to in 2023 oh good question
good question haven't seen Brave me two
mind Minto Minto uh I haven't seen Brave
I haven't seen Lilo in Stitch
matter of fact [ __ ] I got a
whole list of movies I got all my notes
damn look at that let's we'll list off
five random ones
go to my five random ones I got I got I
got a lot of movies here I I don't even
number but I got at least 40 of requests
dang
um
oh I can cross off Princess and the Frog
right now hey Jennifer's Body I really
want to watch ah yeah do it I really
want to see Jennifer's Body I I was on a
Tom Hanks kick for a while
so it's for some reason I just missed
out on all the classic timings
um A League of Their Own I haven't seen
um and I haven't seen uh
Philadelphia I haven't seen it either
I haven't seen 12 Monkeys John and I
have not seen The Goonies no look out
um
dang yeah I
I would I know you haven't seen dread
and I would love to do re-watch it
because I literally only remember a
moment
but I'm like I can't tell you anything
about it other than something about a
drug
and what happens to a character in the
end okay
um first t-shirt I saw that in the
theaters while I was on an edible yeah I
don't remember anything about it sure
absolutely
um
and uh so I would love to but I would
have to be honest and be like I've seen
it before like if I were to react with
you I'd be like I have seen it but I was
on an edible at the time many years ago
so I don't remember it but yeah I
remember a moment because invisible
doesn't start wearing off but by the
time I got to the moment
um and it is a famous moment so that's I
think it's because it's been referenced
a lot this moment that's why I'll
remember it but yeah
um but John has to do Face-Off
take us first off yeah I want to do face
off excited for face I like face off a
lot I think there's a lot of people
often write that off as just like some
cool cheesy action film that I'm like I
think there's more going for this movie
than people who have credit for okay I'm
happy to hear that because I've mostly
been aware of it as a meme so
do that back to back with Conair no okay
see Con Air is just
it's like a Cheesy action movie
um but now Face-Off has like I think
Face-Off has surprisingly good character
work okay well and I mean it's they
trade places and they they really deal
with it and I think there's great
performances from uh John Travolta and
Nicholas Cage yeah I think they do great
jobs there all right when they're
playing their original characters
they're doing excellent
and then when they play other care and
then when they switch I think they do a
great job playing the other ones and it
doesn't feel like an impersonation oh
good and they do characters I think they
do great great work and they really do
[ __ ] that I'm like I don't know why
people always write this movie off as
just a like a Cheesy action film where
I'm like I think it does so much more
than that so it so it manages as soon as
it's countless times it manages to both
have the meme but be a film with actual
reminders that these two actors are
capable yeah the first 20 minutes would
not give you that impression but as it
goes it's it it gets emotional uh yeah I
like face off a lot
um let's see here oh Fight Club I gotta
Watch Fight Club Fight Club yeah it's
another great one
um I have the whole big ass list here
um that's true I agree with that you
know people at the end of the day
I did a day Sarah will talk about the
R-rated stuff with DC they still have to
answer to zaslow
they still got to be profitable even
fight he still has someone to answer to
at the end of the day Mickey Mouse
um and WB is a very they tend to have
very reactive leaders instead of people
who stick to their guns Yeah man they
they change every step of the way game
bro gaming tell them to scroll now I
don't want to scroll yeah I was going to
keep it here these are the comments for
the rest of the show
um let's see here
True Detective season ratings do limit
your marketing though that is true sure
especially when you tend to places like
China China wait a minute wait a minute
we totally missed it oh my God oh my God
what happened Chase oh we had to scroll
oh my God we missed them what happened
here I have noticed because if we spend
too much time on on like keeping the
screen Frozen Yeah it uh just
automatically does this thing hold on we
got it back up here oh my God oh my God
John refresh where's the uh yeah we got
a menu here in case a situation like
this occurred so I can know who the last
one was
that uh The Last of The Last Chance
The Last of Us super Chatters oh my God
I'm so sorry everyone oh what up TJ
TJ from Sam okay okay no no we're right
okay perfect we're right here in terms
of the Super Chat okay perfect perfect
perfect perfect yeah all right cool
see because we are reading other
comments too okay
this might be the most other comments
we've read in the live stream and no
we've cursed ourselves by putting your
chat here in the center of frame now
because then we just look bad if we're
not reading uh yeah what do you
self-centered jerks talking about Alex C
Mountain Mazel Tov on the marriage thank
you for the Super Chat thanks for all
you've given me this year I've given you
so much and now you give us super chat
so you give back in return rip
um who's this
Alex C plus R.I.P oh yes Los says
spookies I am so sad sad to say I'm not
familiar Viva loses spookies is a uh
mostly Spanish language show on HBO uh
Fred Armisen is one of the producers and
is a supporting character but it's about
this group of friends who are you know
are all quirky in sort of Misfits and
they make this business putting together
haunted experiences for people
um and so sometimes it's like I need to
scare somebody or sometimes it's like
I'm throwing a weird party but then you
know other hijinks ensue uh it's it's
very charming and I love it and uh and
yeah I wish it would be back for a
season three I was so excited in fact
because season two dropped just recently
like after such a long break because of
the pandemic and uh and I guess it
wasn't enough
wasn't enough oh I'm sorry to hear that
but yeah I'm looking forward to watching
season two I Love Lucy spookies well one
of us knew what that was yeah high
expectations for Ant-Man three oh yeah
absolutely go Ant-Man we Caitlyn I don't
think we're covering The Witcher blood
origin
as a rooting for Michelle yo learning to
say no to certain things right now and
we have to be a little more decisive at
her going to a whole bunch of reasoning
as to why but no man no please know that
we've done many factoring and
consideration on things but we have
directions we want to go with the
channel next year and December was kind
of an experimental month for it so uh
Sarah Williamson now I knew Elvis hated
being all those beach movies that's
right did you pointed that out earlier
I've seen some of those beach movies too
and who boy howdy uh thoughts in the
FNAF movie Waiting for a trailer that's
all I gotta say yeah waiting for a
trailer who did they just cast they just
cast a couple Austin Butler that's
Freddy yes Freddy Fazbear yeah
yeah it's it's been so long in the
making and it's like there's so many
weird Stakes attached to it like that's
the one that that is a property I'm very
nervous for as much as I'm excited about
Jacob and lordy as soups seeing that
going around quite a bit which one's
Jacob belardi I know I've seen his name
and face oh yeah Josh Thomas and Matthew
Willard from outer space Matthew Lillard
and Josh Hutcherson are in FNAF Jacob
illardi Michael Mack thank you Michael
David hater and Cam Clark just released
a grinch parody song called liquid
Grinch check it out
David hater did a grinch parody song
screenwriter of Scorpion King David he
screaming
at that I think I'm wrong about that
co-road X2 right X-Men X-Men one and
X-Men two yeah both of them yeah you're
thinking co-wrote X-Men one it was the
soul screenwriter for X-Men two yeah
which which he was like secretly brought
on board for uh X-Men one like he wasn't
supposed to but Brian Singer did
something good and and uh I don't think
we're not going to recognize that I'm
pretty sure I'm I'm way wrong about it
I hope you're right
no one on the battlefield I mean to me
he had the first I could be wrong but he
had the most distinct other than like a
[ __ ] Mario or something but if we're
in terms of like cinematic games he had
the most the first most succinct voice
oh yeah dude like it's to the point
where I might be wrong about that to the
point where like we're replacing him
with Kiefer Sutherland was like
blasphemy on the battlefield
I mean if you're gonna replace not a bad
pick no I mean if you got to it did
write The Scorpion King
oh man I did not realize that and and
four episodes of warrior none rest in
peace
uh let's see here I don't know what
happened earlier to happen again and
Watchman uh I hope you all keep watching
the dcau movies yeah man that's right
kicked it off on the right two right
first two ones so there's a few I
haven't seen dude jump in with koi just
be you and I oh really crazy
that koi's not ruining it forever yeah
that way Coy's not sitting here being
like Comics yeah
yeah Riley Wilson Julia Mendez uh I love
your videos my favorite reaction for you
is b99 oh thank you well I didn't know
someone watches those I love those Kayla
v thank you Kayla for the super check
congratulations on your marriage Greg
love you guys Kayla five love you too
Kayla V for Vendetta
I am curious about the new Haunted
Mansion movie with Owen Wilson and and
uh
is it Taraji or is it somebody else
somebody's in that
no well anyway
I'm excited is he still del Toro I don't
know I haven't heard anything about it
this isn't about that hi Tony hi Tony
thank you for being here Tony oh react
to Joyride one dude I know Joyride won
way too well your tail lights out yeah I
love that movie is that the Paul Walker
rated yeah and Steve's on oh dude
not Jessica this is Jessica peel I don't
remember who I know it's like I know
they're doing so well
who is the girl in it I don't think it's
Jessica apparently Justin Simeon is
directing uh the the haunted manager but
let's cool can't wait Joel's working on
that there you go there you go call him
up and see Joyride
this is the right I want to shout out
Bucky Barnes
for uh killing it right now with holding
down this car is around the last I can't
wait for the last of us my God I can't
wait can't wait
pains me when I see other people I've
seen it already
um you'll see it don't worry
I would love to see a live-action Archer
movie as well yeah I'm so behind Archer
oh mother TJ Perry what he was decided
when a fellow Saint Charles Alum shows
up here it was Lily Sobieski actually
enjoyed it yes yes yes yes yes I
remember as a blonde girl yes um I was
like it's not ever heard regarding the
last of us too team Abby or team alley
oh team Ellie Ellie's my all-time like
it used to be Solid Snake but I was like
it's Ellie yeah uh yeah Ellie Ellie's my
favorite character from The Last of Us I
I love her
I just I love like she's when I write
like certain types of female characters
I go she tends to be like yeah that's
like that's like the kind of character I
want to write you know not perfect but
it's still strong
weaknesses very much on display but
courageous based off of the emotional
drive like I [ __ ] love her character
so much Abby all the way like it's sad
so it has no idea what we're talking
about I just like to make people mad I
know Abby is the one you choose if you
want to make people mad
I like Abby though I do I like Abby yep
I got that opinion oh sorry for the
actress who plays her in the show when
it comes finally gets to that point in
the show do you think they will D they
will amend do you know what happens in
last of us too I don't know the
heart-wrenching circumstances but I know
the blunt circumstance between Abby and
Ellie okay
okay uh and it tells me nothing uh but I
think well it doesn't I don't want to
should I say it no don't say it then all
right uh but no I I think I like I like
I like Abby uh quite a bit there but I
think they would I don't know I feel
like they'd be cowards if they don't go
down that route sure
um especially after sticking to their
guns so much on it and and the fact that
there are people who really like and I I
really like Abby
um
I just I don't prefer her but I like her
okay and and I think I think on a sh
especially when you have a [ __ ] my best
comparison I'd say is like when you have
a show like The Walking Dead that exists
and lasted this long I don't see why you
could not get away with an Abby
it's awesome okay
um
one maybe if you guys know Walking Dead
and you know last of us too I think
you'll understand what my comparison is
there of why you couldn't uh of why I
feel like you could totally make an Abby
work on a TV show
um Heather gear hey Heather hey Heather
from patreon
John please read love you guys do you
think movies getting critical Acclaim
influences your opinion of them good
question also congrats to Greg and
thanks to Super Charming John for the
psych reactions absolutely it's one of
my favorites wow
insults I I got to Greg and thanks to
the super Charming job
congrats to regular old normal
Greg I see the negative standard issue
woman
default setting Gray
um yeah movies I think you can it can I
think yeah I mean I eventually readjust
but I think expectation I don't think it
it affects my overall opinion
yeah I feel like there is a certain but
it factors into the conversation I think
yeah it's it's definitely something to
react to uh and I think that it's
possible yeah I mean sometimes you'll
spend your time going like man I didn't
really care for this the same way
everybody else did or like am I you know
do I really like this as much as I think
I do because of just like what I've
heard about how great it's supposed to
be or whatever
um but yeah for the most part I feel
like it's more of a thing to react to I
feel more often than not you come out
and you're like yeah I'm not with most
Critics on this or or you know I don't
get what everybody's talking about I
think this is pretty great you know
we have a button here where we can just
insert an ad yeah I've tried it before
and I don't know exactly like what an ad
just play yeah I don't that's what I
feel like that'd be like disruptive
that's what I assumed it feels weird on
like about a playback is one thing but
on a on a yeah on like a live on a live
be like hey guys I know we got like our
viewers who have been like contributing
money our way but I'm just gonna play
another ad here but here's an ad to to
mess up the real-time experience of all
this yeah and then when I looked after
on the stream where I was like testing
it out it didn't seem like it placed the
ads in the you know like the after the
videos processed you can put ads into it
and I didn't see them there either so I
don't really I'm not sure we'll find out
um next year very excited for that Megan
some love Barbie 2001 Space Odyssey
yeah 2001. I do got to see 2001. the big
lights pointed at me this
big colored lights pointing at you
sitting in this chair yeah
um
let's see here thank you for being an
awesome moderator by the way yeah Bucky
you've been killing it I'm excited for
Super Mario Land at Universal I think
their employee preview is coming up
dude can't wait to get sick of that song
while [ __ ] waiting in line for their
goddamn right yes stop playing the Super
Mario theme song
there are only like three songs in this
universe please turn it off please give
me the evil castle theme
I I think the the revolute I mean the
Lewis Barry and the chat is saying love
Pearl and Mia deserves a nom which is
unlikely to happen I haven't seen any of
those movies but what I do know is
performers and horror based
other shows or movies do not get
recognition they undoubtedly deserve
unless they do elevated horror not even
not even that yeah Tony Collette it is
like
I've I got I'm almost done with Dahmer
it's the long story we're taking to
finish the show I really had a hard time
getting into it in the beginning really
yeah
um it wasn't fun enough for you yeah I'm
like where's all the camp it's all the
American Horror Story came on
why is he playing this so subtle except
computers Evan Peters is a prime example
to me of
like not every season of American Horror
I think he's great every season he's
ever been in uh I I I do think there are
performances in American Horror where
I'm glad he's eventually won like won an
Emmy or Golden Globe right I'm glad he
eventually won for something that was an
American Horror Story but he's a prime
example to me of why has he not even
been nominated yeah like they're in
certain performances it's just
phenomenal but I watched like Dahmer
and
it's like I think we all know that like
of course we know Evan Peters is going
to do a great job as a serial killer
buddies that's what he does best uh but
the
Richard Jenkins as Jeffrey Dahmer's
father
he his performance is so
amazing like it is it is a phenomenal
performance
and I'm like and now you've got me why
do I get the impression he's not even
gonna get considered for a nomination
here I like Evan Peters a whole lot but
you say Richard Jenkins and I ain't
there I mean they got great they have
great scenes together and and I and to
me that like that performance is the one
that I'm like I knew Richard Jacob's
gonna be in here but I didn't realize
we're gonna get this much of
of a performance commissioner Jacobs and
he is so great he's great and I'm like I
just know he's not going to get out of
it that's messed up it's because it's
because it's a of Ryan Murphy horror
show
Richard Jenkins deserves all the love I
do wonder if Indiana Jones lived to the
hype I just like the problem with
Indiana Jones is like when you when you
have this much hype you you kind of need
it to be spectacular to make an
impression yeah you know you can make a
great one but it's got to be phenomenal
you know that's the trouble so many of
these uh franchise and especially Legacy
movies land themselves in is is you you
have to be great yeah otherwise because
because that's what you're doing is you
are you're you're not making the
follow-up installment to a story or
making the follow-up installment of a
legacy yeah you're adding a brick to a
legacy a gold brick yeah what time is it
I think uh meeting to attend all right
yeah we should wrap this up relatively
soon okay
look at the ring Greg has sorry ladies
yeah yeah these live streams are always
filled with women fighting for Craig is
what happened they are they're all
crying now how do you guys know jabby
KOA uh John is jabby's brother yeah they
don't look like it but you know we got
the same we got the same mom thank you
Kevin oh blade was supposed to come out
next year I know and now it's never ever
gonna come out ever Barbie and John Wick
4 who'd you pick to be Batman in the new
DCU
um
Evan Peters Hoyt Holt mcalleny void
holdberg
there we go we got there leave Schreiber
yeah ooh get Ryan Gosling to be Batman
nah
you wanna fight
Vengeance
on the night
Alfred get the Batmobile
[Laughter]
they will make a Pirates of the
Caribbean six just not right now uh
Helen farmer they're making it with it
don't guys look
they need to realize Pirates of the
Caribbean needs to die
before you you bring it back yeah it
used to be like long dead you can't
bring it back as a half sequel you need
like a 20 30 year break like that is not
one of those franchises because it is it
is it is part it's Jack Sparrow in the
Pirates of the Caribbean bottom yeah it
does absolutely true so you can't you
cannot no no version of pirates is truly
gonna generate a Mass Appeal
if you go we're doing it with women no
that's not going to work yeah we're
gonna do it with a younger cast that's
not gonna work I feel like it's just not
you got to give it like a 20 to 30 year
break and you've got to revisit this
franchise yeah and you gotta get a new
Johnny Depp or something like somebody
who naturally Rises to that sort of
unlikely but interesting character I
don't know yeah you need things to
happen organically
um Connor Belmont thank you so much
buddy oh Christmas
2023 is definitely Ant-Man in the lost
quantumania well you're gonna get your
wish fulfilled very early on here
February is done I can sit back and wait
for that top 10 list damn [ __ ] what else
is possibly gonna come out this year
um it's okay well we're happy for you
thank you for the Super Chat you guys
are the best keep going you're the best
this is Robert passes Batman also
getting canceled I doubt it oh it's way
too much of an ass and it made money it
profited yeah it's in safe territory
it's a profitable three-hour movie
that's a tall order safe territory and
it's almost R-rated like that's too much
of a debate with Black Adam
of like to make money or not
um too much of a debate and it's all it
seems like there's really one way and
and then
um and Wonder Woman 84 had that like the
the origin of pandemic release and and
like so
the reception was not good and I believe
the exchange that was put out publicly
by Patty Jenkins and James Gunn that we
have not talked about but uh yeah I mean
I if it doesn't line like Batman is safe
because it's not connected
yeah and I feel like weirdly the one
character you can definitely do in
elseworld's version with is Batman
because they've already set themselves
up for the audience willing to take on
multiple Batman and never apologize for
all the uh
scroll back up what was it it's
Castlevania yeah for the Castlevania
never apologize never apologize Greg
often often has spoken highly of the
show Castleman is a [ __ ] yeah I do want
to watch a girl walks home alone tonight
let me go with the Blu-ray years ago oh
yeah I saw that on your shelf the other
day I was like Greg has the oh that's
right
it's a good movie it's an interesting
movie you know what I would want to see
done From Dusk Till Dawn four but don't
call it From Dusk Till Dawn for with
George Clooney oh and not Tarantino
well he's dead he's dead uh but they'll
bring him back I think if Tarantino
wrote it and and uh Rodriguez Rodriguez
directed and it was like an old man
um Seth old man Gekko yeah like still in
Mexico or some [ __ ] yeah he probably
just make some cheesy ass vampire Hunter
probably wouldn't work at all I guess
like I rewatched it not long ago and I'm
like George Clooney was [ __ ] awesome
in this movie and I still don't yeah oh
really I thought I feel like it's been a
character Arc of your viewing I used to
not like him for some reason but I think
I was just so aware I was watching
George Clooney I mean yeah it's hard not
to be
um but he is he is slick in that movie
oh he's great he's great I like him a
lot
um and that tattoo so cool
Gary Smith love you guys please make my
excess by shouting me out love you Gary
Smith
[Music]
shouted at you Disney princess spirit
animal oh that's a good question
um
can't wait for a movie with a talking
cat that isn't a musical
the Garfield
a talking cat uh Stuart Little
dude
almost cats and dogs no my talking cat
movies
have you guys watched big hero six I saw
in the theater I unfortunately have
that's the that's the stage I'm at in my
life I unfortunately unfortunately why
did I watch all these classic movies now
that First Time watches are a thing why
did I ever watch Terminator too
um hi Greg and John Chase Gardener
buddies I'm excited for Christopher
Nolan's Oppenheimer and John Wick 4.
yeah who the [ __ ] isn't Chase yeah get
an original and and the original answer
point out point out um I'm excited for I
I only know big movies
it was a small movie that's coming up
I'm excited for uh uh
hold on we got the list right here you
should do Black Swan too I'm excited
Black Swan too will be great that'll be
very highly anticipated I'm excited for
Martin Scorsese Roosevelt starring
Leonardo DiCaprio I'm excited for
Legally Blonde three I am excited blonde
harder one three
um David Gordon greens The Exorcist so
he can ruin it so he can make a Trilogy
out of that yeah and they're doing the
same thing it's gonna be direct sequel
the first one just what everyone wanted
especially fans of the Xbox they should
pick it up moments after the first one
literally
DH everybody face plant people on
uh uh the Ghostbusters afterlife sequel
the one Wonka uh yeah there you go I'm
sorry there's been no no talk at all in
this chat about Transformers when I feel
like that looks like the first time
we're getting a real Transformers movie
like the Transformers movie we've all
been waiting for projectors enduring
many Michael Bay movies and then and
Bumble getting a fresh start with
bumblebee this finally looks like the
Transformers movie that we all wanted
here's hoping man go I'm rooting for
Stephen cable Jr I hope he brings it out
get those Beast Wars yes everyone's been
crazy here cheater
[Music]
Andrew Saba my theory on Oppenheimer is
Nolan will use black and white and color
film to signify
different timelines yes that is a good
theory and that sounds reasonable
especially because you see him aging
different ages in the trailer black and
white after atom bomb color before
similar to Memento see that's what I
mean going back to Memento time by the
way last name pronounced Cebu like Sega
cool yeah no I agree with that I like
Nolan messing around with time that's
what he does best
time time is an interesting concept
because like when you look up at the
stars those are like millions of years
away yeah you know it's like an interest
like you're literally peering into time
when you like see stars yeah it's
fascinating time is an interesting
construct
anyway still chewing on my theory that
werewolf by night was set in the TVA
good it's in the nightmare Department
it's been three months I'm still
thinking about watching my Night Theory
I've gone over this many times the
secret Loki season 2.5 where it will
finite there's gotta be more to this
bad thing is the key man thing is the
key to Loki season two Janine the
machine the machine
speaking of people of color hi
[Laughter]
we're excited to have you here am I the
only one hyped for Magic Mike's Last
Dance are you out of your [ __ ] mind
never Valentine's Day I'm there
him in Salma Hayek dancing the night
away I gotta see the first two Magics
Mike dude yeah reaction I don't think so
note react to that you will get age
restrictions
[Music]
it's not even that sexual awesome that's
the funny part it's not super sexual
it's family dance entertainment I'm like
not like you're seeing a bunch of wing
and dingalings flinging around or
something not like that RoboCop scene
where he's shooting all the wing and
dingalings go look that up it's fun but
yes I am excited for it yeah it's his
last dance looks nothing like the first
two
the Steven soderber's returning baby oh
it's weird it looks so generic it's okay
it'll be better in the action it's like
the most generic take you can do and I'm
like this doesn't feel like there's a
unique vibe to this every magic
Soderberg just want the money yeah
because that's the kind of guy he did
something special with the first the
first one was surprisingly like nuanced
um John Wick screen create a mission
impossible or top in my list I mean
Mission Impossible Rogue Nation the year
came out was my favorite movie that year
dude I got a lot of crap for that yeah
they did not say Revenant
oh I still gotta watch the ruin it I
feel like that that's one of those
movies that feels like a chore to me
where I'm like I gotta I gotta sit down
and I'm like sure and but but hey I'm
sure it'll be gripping nothing but a
experience okay good it is from
beginning to end it is it is it is an
atmospheric
it's like the plot is [ __ ] remarkably
simple okay good it is do you not know
the plot he's just in the out in the
wilderness trying to not die right no
okay there's an actual like he's got a
feeling to lose a bet to a bear and he's
gonna fight the bear it's a really easy
plot to follow okay and it no it's it is
just a it's it's a mood Elemental piece
okay it's man versus nature on a quest
okay for a very I mean the fact you
don't know Crystal Skull no the fact you
don't know what like the plot is very
very simple okay and it's about as basic
of a plot as it gets but the the the
execution and ex and experience is very
unique okay
um so but yeah it's like it was like
kind of when you say like Avatar has
like an actual really simple like they
both have very simple plots but the
execution in the world is is the journey
and then here it's just a lot more
violent adding the Revenant to my list
oh my God the Revenant is an amazing
movie okay well and then I'm excited to
see it I loved it it's really violent
that's good all right it's very very
violent I'm gonna put it under action
and crime
or very Warren Western I don't know
it'll break my heart if you don't like
Dumb and Dumber
oh sure yeah I know and and hey they
shot I saw some of the uh little mural
thing they had at the Stanley Hotel
about Dumb and Dumber yeah and a bit to
the moon and according to the tour guide
on The Shining tour uh Jim Carrey like
put it in his contract at one point that
like he refused to shoot there again for
like some other movie that was gonna
shoot there or something like that
because he had too many weird
experiences at the Stanley Hotel yeah
yeah he's a he's a [ __ ] um
um let's see here Jim Carrey haunts the
Stanley Hotel thank you Janine though
thank you Janine project
love that Moana reaction of the day most
authentic thing I've said in ages thank
you thank you yeah I really love that
movie that was great oh John's reaction
to Blade someday
um yeah one yeah that would make that
happen I'm gonna make blade happen yeah
I'm excited I've got more movies to do I
have so many stories of show We're not
gonna be able to get these movies up in
frankly real rejects been enjoying
movies more movies are such a blast and
more of a more of a rewarding experience
loving doing these you know so you just
don't have time for everything it's a
good way to kill birds they're very much
and very very very much involved in the
edits some people don't may not realize
that but we're very like it's actually
been edited or were or were like very
much in the process so like and the
thumbnails too we're not like here you
go
do it and upload it yeah narrowed down
these specific faces here's a couple
graphics and like a few hours of my own
on Glass Onion uh in the middle of the
night so yeah I spent a few hours my own
so it's it's not just like you're so
people might think we just filmed but no
no
we commit that's what I mean is like the
time of it
um Bill Skarsgard is also the new Crow
yeah I like that sure I can see that and
that's what makes him being a
protagonist yeah and I think it's just a
great dramatic actor and I think it'd be
a good Nosferatu yeah I mean slash three
boys got a new song out hell yeah oh
let's do it they're great yeah yeah I'm
happy to see him play that oh people
love the Teen Wolf show with Tyler
hecklin thank you for the comment on the
shirt um oh my God a pig would be a
great one yeah
I've heard people say that's their
favorite movie from that year I really
want to see Pig yeah I don't I love Nick
I love Nicholas Cage so much because of
yeah I love that he spans the entire
gamut more than any other actor
definitely except maybe Steve's though
uh and Eric Robert John has not seen
Lilo and Stitch I haven't yeah and you
haven't seen League of Their Own and now
there's a TV show watch them together at
the same time we will side-by-side
reaction and that will save us from all
the copyright stuff because both movies
will be overlapping no one will be able
to tell what the scenes are this is not
a substitute if anything it's not an
experience for anyone I think it's gonna
be really off-putting people are gonna
rush out and get their own copy
immediately just to cleanse this taste
away Connor Stevens thank you for the
Super Chat
Home Alone totally ripped off a badass
French film called deadly games it's a
horror fever dream it's like a horror
fever dream version one of my favorite
krimbus films look up the year deadly
games came out John we are going to
confirm whether or not you are full of
[ __ ] Connor it's the French remix I want
just once for it to be like some other
country 89. all right fine confirm home
Home Alone 1990. yeah I think it'll
probably be yeah I don't know probably
too close together and they take a long
time to make yeah especially back then
could have been very coincidental this
does look kind of neat though on
Christmas Eve a resourceful young boy
has to defend himself and his
grandfather from a killer dressed as
Santa Claus that sounds like a different
enough plot yeah I mean it sounds like
it's got some Silent Night deadly
nighter or one of those killer it's like
killer Santa movie plus kid home
invasion yeah they should do a home
alone five with uh Macaulay Culkin and
and then uh the bandits returning yes
Macaulay Culkin's a grown ass man but it
should take place moments after Home
Alone 2. yes they're still in New York
he's got to find his way home they break
out of the truck taking them to prison
oh God that'll be so good people will
show up dude kick start that uh
Buckaroo Banzai is not a bad cop Shop's
not a bad one either Cop Shop have not
seen Buckaroo Banzai is a delight
I should do a Face-Off too we need to
switch faces again
I want to take my face back face back
face back Jenny's back back face sack
face I am Pat back my well-time favorite
murder was driving double feature Connor
face off at like age 11. no alcohol
required driving that sounds awesome
tacular yeah wow I'm jealous damn the
third rule of Fight Club you must watch
Fight Club ah great call it'll happen
that in zodiac never seen zodiac either
oh toadiak's great yeah I want to see it
all I know about zodiac is that one
aerial shot of the car
zodiac actually has some of the most
underrated use of CGI there are things
in there that I had no clue were CGI
like buildings designed and stuff sure
and I was like what uh cars and stuff
that is like Flawless where I had zero I
didn't even question that like is this
is this stuff I just assumed it was the
set yeah you look right fast yeah that's
always the most mind-blowing CPI and and
that happens in a lot of like a lot of
the backdrops you see in a lot of movies
are not what they're actually shooting
against
I wish
um The Sopranos came out now so people
could do reactions and see what the
finale was actually like on YouTube does
everyone knows the ending of that even
if you haven't seen it yeah Don't Stop
Believing uh Dacia also nation's always
watching also hasn't seen face off dude
perfect the new monster react together
hey maybe maybe you guys check out
Dash's YouTube channel I'll give him a
full reactive a little collab do a
little collaboration
reaction collaboration reactions no
breathing don't give a [ __ ] look at my
um
[Music]
direct Marvel question dude somebody
Terence Howard saying Tony Tony
uh you guys think the new Avengers are
gonna be in cap New World Order
um just a bunch of of dead beats a bunch
of nobodies yeah just a bunch of guys
whose costumes don't fit give a [ __ ]
about them there's gonna be a bunch of
jokes gonna be a bunch of dealers
characters the Branded me happy holidays
you awesome guys happy holidays to you
Brandon good to see you again hope
you're doing okay congrats again Mary
Gregory for Scream Six next year should
put should have I gotta change that
thumbnail you know dude
um ruined it Shadow bone inside job I
have not seen inside job I am excited
for invincible season two I need to
catch up on Rick and Morty I'm like a
season and a half behind on Rick and
Morty it's funny as John started a show
way before I know and now I'm only up to
season three yeah
four through six but I love me some Rick
and Morty
dude it is a special one very impressive
show should Marvel and corporate Avatar
3D effects towards future Avengers
projects yes but not unless James
Cameron's help let them botch it
I mean terrible job I mean it's a
foregone conclusion that that'll happen
like any of these Innovations will
eventually be democratized and
everyone's gonna start jumping on them
now bring us a lead up part two cowards
Zack sisters hey Greg and June just want
to say I love the channel and you guys
are hilarious been watching for a long
time any anime you guys are hyped for
all of the live-action Netflix remakes
of course Demon Slayer just got thrown
on the pile Full Metal Alchemist it's
coming one piece
Academia live action it's all Darren
aronofsky's my hero Academia all takes
place on all my losing his powers yes oh
yeah I just vomiting blood and staring
at himself in the mirror and his eyes
are sinking further into the back of his
said let's do it I would love to see it
all might's unhealthy obsession with
being number one um I'm excited for uh
oh my God Attack on Titan to finally end
I want to see that chainsaw guy anime
I've heard good things about that yeah
I've heard good really great things
about that I've heard it's wild but also
good yeah what came as you think would
show up in Deadpool 3 all of them uh all
the fox Universe characters all the fox
Universe characters everyone from the
Green Lantern movie who hasn't uh you
know been back in a while see people
like Abby I've seen some love for Abby
this person not liking Abby
it's okay Neil druckman choice for
Justice League director
John Krasinski
uh Stallone a couple good movies
[Laughter]
yeah Brenda V
thank you Brandon for the Super Chat
have you guys heard of
skina marink it's an indie horror come
out next month that's been going viral
on Tick Tock no I haven't wow
that'd be more attention what goes viral
on Tick Tock as a good way to gauge if
it would be a proper SEO one for YouTube
to cover here also John John yeah are
you a fan of analog horror like the back
rooms or the Mandela catalog I don't
know what those are actually as is is
analog horror a different kind of uh is
it like Mumble core or something like
that is it it's somewhere in between
elevated horror and shitty horror okay I
do like shitty horror yeah I do have to
say uh I don't know I I would love to
check this out oh I know what I I I
don't know how to explain analog horror
but I am familiar with uh is it like a
collective where like people contribute
is it like a growing yeah would it would
it be sort of a Kim yes and clarify I
might be totally wrong on my
understanding of it is is it sort of
akin to uh
not like SBC maybe more like Creepypasta
SCP SCP is it something like SCP true
comparisons to various other horror
Trends in media including the
photography of liminal spaces the SCP
okay yeah project it's not exactly like
that but it's oh cool they say akin to
you you've just turned me on to a whole
new idea I was not aware of but I am
excited about and uh yeah I'll
definitely be keeping a skinamarink is
uh oh no it's it's playing in January
but hey I can get they're like actual
movies though yeah yeah yeah oh how cool
it's only got two two and a half stars
on IMDb though yeah what do you
expecting I'm excited I'm excited to
check this out though come on it's a
whole new yeah I mean you know I'm
excited to see what this turns into
though you've exposed me to something
new and I'm excited for it I love horror
and that's uh I do got trips and they
hold on a sec I was like all right go go
all right oh
my god oh Dark Side uh now the Deadpool
is in the MCU uh many people and and
certainly koi included are hoping
they'll do some kind of Deadpool kills
the fox Marvel Universe uh as a means of
sort of in uh incorporating everything
it's two degrees outside stuck at the
house can't wait for winter to be over
sometimes it can't get unbearably cold
it's nice coming back to California I
should be like you know what I like the
weather right it'll take 45 degrees
it'll take 50 degrees why not
California's way way more beautiful I
will I haven't seen The Tick Tock Olivia
it's impossible right now I'm in the
middle of a live stream honey we must
separate our personal lives this is
business time all right I prefer on that
table
and all you do is nag me about Tick Tock
swimming happens
you're at one one time for the sound
board see I don't know why it has
cameras like that yeah all right guys
look we gotta unfortunately gotta skip
around I feel terrible if we miss some
super shits and did we get that this one
oh my God I'm so sorry
um Darth Revan most displayed star show
2023
I think mandalorian's too easy of an
answer is acolytes this year because I
heard that's a focuses on assists yeah
and I'm like that sounds like [ __ ]
man and uh I'm pretty cool
Ahsoka I gotta go with Ahsoka still
because I love the characters so much
and I love ahsoko much so much
I'm trying to make this work so much so
much I love it so much I'm looking
forward to the imperator Riva show
um uh but oh yes
I'm looking forward to the mon mothma
therapy show with her and her husband
this is her and Jose would be like the
show Intrigue I was about to say Gabriel
Burns in here couples counseling episode
what I say in therapy tell me about the
hypocritic oath tell me about what
parents said the other day
um yeah
how do you feel in your Loveless
marriage yeah I would uh I'd say that
anyway
um
myself
happy holidays guys I got a wrench here
thanks for the great content have you
guys watched the rehearsal I really
enjoyed it
I have a few friends who are raged when
they watched it but not me I felt I
finally found something understood
not like a super graphic movie I have
not heard of the rehearsal the rehearse
comedy oh it's a comedy with Nathan
Fielder oh I want to check this out I've
been meaning to check out his stuff
sounds like a really violent movie John
I've heard this is wild uh yeah you know
it I've made a mistake the menu people
love the menu I want to check out the
menu uh but yeah I want to check out the
rehearsal I've heard a few things about
this show and it sounds fascinating
Nathan Fielder is doing some interesting
shiz out there you know I realized just
yesterday one day we're gonna have ai
therapists oh my that's disturbing to
think about crazy one day we'll have
therapists oh I wrote a script about
that actually
I must mean that a lot of people have
had their own version
I got a movie about a killer Uber driver
yeah a haunted house where people
actually die an Airbnb that's evil
a God of all this is right here ready to
go buy them Hollywood
mine's more of a um like
uh
thing in the like you keep your
therapist with you wherever you go oh
cool yeah
so like there's a positive transforming
movie and it never goes wrong just watch
the ideal happen as some guy's life
becomes amazing
pandemic you haven't seen the Mission
Impossible movies start your reaction
Channel such a good experience because
the first one is not at all what the
franchise evolves into it is just a a
tactical Espionage film it's an ensemble
James Bond and uh it's it's like mainly
dialogue
yeah it's more of a mystery and and uh
not much action and
and then the second one is is you either
[ __ ] hate the [ __ ] out of how boring
it is or it's a random guilty pleasure
and I don't know how that is a guilty
pleasure for people because I'm like
oh my God it's taking forever the action
does not hold up to me as a kid I
thought that movie was rad and as an
adult it is a tedious experience kind of
hate it um I I hate that it's a tedious
movie Mission Impossible suddenly three
is like whoa this is really engaging in
person
four is like wow what a blast and then
it just kind of stays that way and it's
like now watch Tom Cruise risk his life
and it's uh it's awesome
um
I don't know playing centuries I thank
you for saying you love this channel
kevonta Caldwell
police junko how do you guys feel I
don't know about Cobra Kai and your
choices they made at the end because I
think it should end at six I think they
shouldn't they probably got one more
season and then one more solid season
uh yeah no I think um I think doing like
a good wrap around where it all
eventually comes back to crease sure
it's a good way to do it yeah
and he's broken out yeah I know I think
they can keep it going for a while I
feel like they I have something I get
the impression these actors are like not
paid that much sure I'm just gonna get
that Vibe it's like such a massive show
and yet I get the impression that they
probably don't put much money to them do
they they don't yeah it doesn't have to
be super budget but at the same time you
also get the sense they don't have that
much budget to begin yeah and it
probably costs not not the same as
having like a celebrity in your movie
but you know Ralph Macchio has to be the
the top toppest dollar you're paying for
and then yeah everybody else and they
have a lot of prominent cases well the
Karate Kid franchise is so amazing
because like Cobra Kai can end and then
the franchise Karate Kid could just fall
off again right it could just fall off
and people like I don't give a [ __ ]
anymore
and then 20 years later you follow
Miguel as an as an older person you know
like you could keep the cycle humming
yeah exactly it's kind of crazy that you
can sort of do that and you'll always
have descendants of crease or Terry
silver or whoever to go up against York
side for the Mario movie [ __ ] yeah
that's awesome Little Mermaid yes
bring it have not seen the Enola homes
have not have you have not I've watched
um the end of both of them though oh
good you know obviously I just wanted to
know what the mystery wrap-up was
um damn we do gotta head out shortly
Frank alcaccio love y'all thank you
Frank love you too happy holidays we
need some coin rink and Spider-Man woman
from the comics
do it we're talking about something
that's just strictly the comics yet with
koi yeah but we will it'll it'll happen
someday you never know are there any
shows or movies we watched before Moon
night oh my God you gotta start right
from the beginning you gotta watch the
entire MC you gotta watch the entire MCU
title everything
too and then watch and then watch Moon
night and they pretty much got
everything kind of uh solved for you
yeah because most of the plots are just
Easter eggs from the previous movies
yeah so if you haven't yeah and upcoming
movies you just teases so you really
don't know what they're doing gotta just
check them out but yeah yeah for the
most part dude you'll never be able to
watch Moon Knight until the MCU is
concluded
all right guys let's do the two streams
I think we got two streamlabs oh do we
really yeah
yeah we have streamlabs from our guy
flev tavius Doran all right we're just
gonna read them all right Flav congrats
Greg hope you had a beautiful day kind
of uh came in late into the stream so I
don't know what's been said but I'm just
gonna spam some of my most anticipated
shows in films Last of Us Kaleidoscope
with Giancarlo Esposito secret invasion
is that's about 2023. oh no the show is
sorry I think it'll Secret Wars my bad
uh Mando season three that 90s show
Curious to hear if you're excited for
that I'm not good that's so good if he
goes on to say you season four Penn
Badgley in the house fast 10 uh Indiana
Jones Mission Impossible and The Hunger
Games the valid The Ballad of songbirds
and snakes oh my God that is too much
title the more I hear about I didn't
even know the more I hear about this
Hunger Games are you really excited for
it do you really want to see Corey
Elena's Snow's Origins I I really like
the first two Hunger Games movies I was
not a big fan of the last two and now
I'm pretty cool I'm like oh I I just
don't care
but when they announced House of the
Dragon
we didn't even cover the troops I didn't
really care and then that ended up being
one of my favorite shows of the Year
sure so that's my main Saving Grace of
Hope for the Johnson surprisingly it's
not it's like I don't care [ __ ] at all
but maybe
true but maybe I appreciate that I'm not
familiar with kaleidoscope it's funny
Olivia hasn't seen breaking bad and so
I've been showing her Breaking Bad and
she just got to the first episode of
season three and got to see John Carlos
was you know and that's which he has in
the restaurant
when Walter White's trying to be like I
know it's you you're the one I'm
supposed to meet with
and he's just playing nice owner of El
Pollo so Manos Los Pollos Hermanos that
he just switches into weird nothing
unlike Mr White I'm just like oh I'm so
bad [ __ ]
I'm excited to revisit I haven't watched
the full Breaking Bad since since the
first time oh my God
it was magic like few things your Beth
is good Jesse
it's better
so you're watching that show and he's
like breaking into Jesse's house he's
like where's the product Jesse where's
the meth is
like what shall we see [ __ ] like this go
down yeah where's where's the method
and you're just like find the mouth come
on
everything depends on this one
your whole family's future depends on
the math find it
yeah find as many at risk youths and
offload this [ __ ] come on and then he
gets to call his wife's having the baby
and he has the other self the bathroom
scene when you're born and you're just
like ah what a tough what a tough
position
uh we would all sell them I would sell
the meth it's a million dollars the baby
can wait yeah yeah the baby will be
pleased with this and be like I would
have done the same thing Dad thank you
um yeah I'll end it on shavin's question
here
um but yeah good recommendations that
are pandemic for John to check out for
Sean C and I'm excited for the Mario
movie The God of War show
I think it would be cool if they decided
to
um
I think it would be cool if they because
the first three God of War games
he's just kind of mad I honestly haven't
played them I've watched like the
in-depth videos going over them
um so that way I could play because I
was like I guess I should watch these
before playing the first God With God of
War for PS4 create tell us and um Kratos
is just but I think it works I I don't
think you I really needed I didn't need
to watch those videos
um like it has that cool mysterious
effect about his past if you if you just
played God of War
and uh
because you could tell it's like a
tortured Soul over his past life
but in the first three God of War games
he is just good God of War he's just
like [ __ ] bad all the time and he's
just like screaming and I think it would
be cool if he did do those storylines
but brought more depth to it
and and then you get as opposed to just
going right to the game that everyone
loves you know
um yeah I think if you if you did uh do
that but I don't know I mean it's on
Amazon
and they're kind of an up and down
relationship for me right now why as
long as they put enough money into it
it'll be great as long as it looks
pretty as long as it looks good make it
pretty make it pretty
you can make anything pretty nowadays
that's the problem everything is easy to
look pretty you gotta make things iconic
and in a day and age where you get stuff
like Avatar the way of water where you
can still make it mind-blowingly pretty
mm-hmm
that's even harder for you to get James
Cameron to direct rings of power season
two sure that would actually be awesome
I mean it would probably work out just
great all right guys we gotta end this
right now but um I want to thank you all
for being here
um please be sure to
leave a like
um thank you for everyone who's
contributors super chats thank you to
flev for the street flips thank you
thank you fly for that streamline
and um I I want to say Merry Christmas
and I hope you all have a Happy New Year
probably do another live stream next
week yeah but honestly you know like I'm
I'm I'm trying to take it a little bit
easier uh there was like a lot of
additional editing and stuff that was
doing like literally like till the day
before the wedding and a lot of
traveling and stuff and and there's a
whole other
thing that I'm dealing with that I'm not
going to talk publicly about but some
[ __ ] went down with a company at a
wedding it's a whole thing so it's been
a lot so I'm trying to take it a little
bit easier right now
um
which means uh probably just you know
only do like eight hours to nine hours
instead of like the usual like 12 13.
but I enjoyed this live stream a lot
it's really chill and laid back and
relaxed yeah it was nice thank you for
reversing for talking with you thank you
for joining me thank you for being here
Jeff yeah of course happy to be here
it's good it was nice yes looking
forward to next week all right guys well
thank you for being here and um tip your
waitress leave a like show some love
this Christmas try to enjoy yourselves
okay yeah go to shopzeroedition.com all
that stuff yeah have a great time to be
an influencer I'll see you guys
and now this live stream is concluded
peace out Pieces good movie